un scénario
blanc a dit il
[Applaudissements]
c'est quelque chose d'émouvant pouvait
pour tout le québec
j'ai touché la cercueil puis j'ai amassé
merci
moi c'est un rêve d'enfance
avec guy lafleur bon état de cagnes
quand on s'approche de l'attendre il ya
une émotion qui viennent
ce programme de ne pas venir celui qui
une dernière fois
bonjour mesdames et messieurs ici
patrice froid et toute l'équipe de radio
canada en direct devant la cathédrale
marie reine du monde nous allons vivre
ensemble au cours des prochaines heures
cette ligne d'arrivée de ces hommages
que nous vivons
collectivement depuis plus de dix jours
une vague d'amour une vague d'émotion
devant cet homme qui est beaucoup plus
qu'un joueur de hockey je pense qu'on a
tous compris qu'ils représentent est
profondément ce que nous voulions être
des gagnants des gens attentionné pour
les autres des gens généreux la
cérémonie les portes de la cathédrale
marie-reine-du-monde que vous voyez
viennent d'ouvrir donc 9 heures les
portes ouvrent la cérémonie commencera à
11h nous allons vivre ensemble tous ces
moments à la fois l'erreur procession du
centre bell des anciens joueurs des
dignitaires beaucoup de dignitaires sont
attendus ici mais beaucoup de gens
ordinaires et c'était le voeu de la
famille c'était le voeu de monsieur
lafleur vous le savez c'est peut-être la
chose qu'on a répété le plus souvent guy
lafleur était bien avec le monde était
bien quand il parlait aux gens étaient
bien quand il signait des autographes
il se nourrissait beaucoup de cette
présence des gens et il y aura deux
écrans géants qui ont été déjà installés
devant la cathédrale
marie-reine-du-monde et le public pourra
comme vous à la maison suivre cette
cérémonie on a été touchée je suis allé
hier mois rendent mai dernier hommage
devant le cercueil au centre bell il y
avait quelque chose de très émouvant de
voir tous ces gens défiler au centre
bell voyait des photos avec moi
serge savard et mario tremblay d d
camarades de la première heure des
joueurs que vous connaissez bien des
amis qui ont connu toutes sortes de
choses avec monsieur lafleur d'abord
bonjour merci d'être scindé patrice jeu
merci d'être là je savoir qu'en savez
vous oui on savait qu'ils étaient mais
ils n'avaient vous quand même été étonné
de l'ampleur des réactions
auraient hommage
nous on se met en scène et on l'a
rencontré au mois de septembre la
journée de sa faillite le 20 septembre
c'est la dernière fois que les anciens
canadiens on ne plus avoir les langues
avec lui par watts plaisir que suri
dernier mais l'on était quand même assez
bien renseigné puis on savait tous que
ce serait une rouge qui la flyer pas
laissé personne indifférent puis reste
un gars qui fait une différence il le
fait aussi après sa carrière à youtube
beaucoup de personnes de même d'aller
les derniers les derniers moments de sa
quête de sa vie et a continué son fonds
pour le chemin de montréal
il ya plein personnellement les
donateurs signant un chandail l'y
poussent à 5 10 minutes avec une détente
quand même eu trop mal malade d'un
dernier mois il était je le disais
attentionné il y était et y quand vous
regardez vous regardez pour réel mais
juste pour continuer ce que recherchent
des tentes au canton nord le fêter ses
soixante dixième année son 70e
anniversaire de naissance
vous savez que c'est la dernière fois
qu'on le voyait alors au lieu de dire il
ya eu des pleurs puis avant l'année car
cette route sbsr qu'ils aillent il a
pointé guy qui était toujours le joker
d'une équipe alors faisait une coupe de
farce on commençait à rire un peu une
demi-heure après basta les pleurs qui
revenait bien on savait le sait ce
qu'elle a fait et puis je pense que nous
faisons a fait aussitôt qu' on avait
devant nous on serait plein nos anciens
souvenirs moustiques par leur situation
ils devenaient très laid larme à l'oeil
trente secondes après bon commencer d'un
dali ben oumar on était un homme avec
ses deux garçons le budget fausses on
l'a beaucoup dit
le côté flamboyant comme joueur
vous avez joué avec lui de nombreuses
années comment s'était rappelée nous
répète côté le côtoyer tous les jours
bien moi quand je te vivait plus
canadien chacun en soit 14 sur les
quinze que je t'avais des biens avant -
les mauges ta ville à 18 ans et c'est là
les six années suivantes
c'est là que guy lafleur a pris son
envol qui pendant six saisons il a
terminé le premier marqueur de la
dédiant doc et dimanche 10 à hangzhou
cour où jouent aux joies on each en juin
on est sous le vent des joints on ne les
relie sièges de première classe pour on
voit guy lafleur évolué à chaque fois
comme ça mais c'est un go qui non
seulement grâce au talent un message au
fond d'un ravin parce qu'à 20 trop en
avance je vois bourgeois et moins
sérieux je re - fait joie - pour écoute
lui la chance qu'ils ont eue puis la
malchance qui a eu ses dérivés canadien
s'il t'arrivait qu'une bonne équipe
poussive été repêché par les ciseaux
jeunes comme celles qui ont fini
derniers cette année là et a raconté 58
le première année crise et certains
disent qu'à montréal on l'a commencé
lentement puis par ta peau sur le
premier jeu de puissance avec 20
conseillers qui tint à vannes alors il
donne l deuxième jeu de puissance mais
y'a marqué 28 buts y'a quoi par sana
montréal qui m'arrivait du buste n est
quand même pas une année désastreuse et
il ne se satisfait pas de ce qu'il
faisait en voulait toujours plus il y
avait un côté perfectionniste comme si
lui
il ne se voyait pas mais n'allez plus
roanne et le comme le champion il
voulait plus plus laisser patrie c'est
super médiateur je pense que les digues
ont tous passé par lens jean-guy indique
l'organisation des mois aussi dis moi ce
que j'aurais scier le guy lafleur
surtout c'est que malgré son statut de
super vedette guy lafleur le syngof
sursaut y est toujours demeuré un code
source auxerre j'ai toujours été un gars
gentil s'est jamais pris feu vert pour
le nombreuses manches puisque j'ai
toujours imprécises guy lafleur moi
c'est que comme aux autres d'ailleurs
ils ont toujours laissé leur ego à la
porte car guy lafleur est mentionné où
on ne voyait les concernés l'espagne à
cause de moi sa cause de l'équipe
successeur les canadiennes montréal
telle équipe c'est la camaraderie si on
était comme des frères certaines grandes
familles qu'on aime mais
il ne t'a mis à rire avec un droit comme
ça dont le regard des autres
il vient d'un autre planète que ça
arrive à deux ans la brebis jean zoa
5h30 à rabat il ya là des messages ici
il ya faisait plus en fait ces
braillards
et a pour lui le programme de relaxer
beaucoup on arrivé à 5h30 de
[Rires]
lancer des rondelles sur
vous à la fin de sa période du canadien
c'était plus difficile puis vrais
échanges et vous vouliez pas est ce que
vous avez fait la paix totalement avec
lui après lorsque ça s'est réglé aussi
rester un petit nuage gris moi j'ai
toujours eu de très bonnes relations en
vue des 500 d'une manière d'un jour
d'audi la faille a pris sa retraite 6
tout ça s'entend des journaux qu'on le
poussait à la porte ce projet mais mais
mais y est à peu près prendre sa
retraite puis la regretter n'oubliez pas
qu'il ya personne appartient canadien
est à partir de ce moment-là kidjo jus
revenir au jeu revenir au jeu layton
ivoiriser de mal à ça qui me change est
ici
charles canadien qui avait changé en
libye libre
partie des
mayas décidé quelques années après y'a
dix titres faire un retour au jeu vont
la libérer mais c'est la fois patrice
france était une bonne chose pour 10 c
est aller vers un juste milieu qui vient
aussi bien aux forums les marques de but
canadien gagne termine sa carrière avec
les nordiques de québec où il joue et
qui remportent chacun un lot il ya
boucle
c'est ce que ces jeunes 1 3 1 prend sa
retraite et le prix un peu jeunes
qui avaient diminué ou italie italie
mais avec un gros con qui ces gens comme
un petit joint un
jeu par al ses rideaux défensifs c'est
un attrape aux poudres dans le jeu qui
est guy lafleur aime jouer alors y'a pas
produit beaucoup plus baisse à celle sas
et birsa se 1200 commencé il y en avait
encore deux dames messieurs bonne
cérémonie
je vous souhaite une belle cérémonie
qu'on vaut vivre tous ensemble parce que
ça a été fera pas devoir vous êtes à
louhans belle légende qui tenait à lui
rendre un dernier hommage
incroyable quand même populaire
incroyable la dernière fois j'ai entrevu
rester ici avec jean ping exactement on
était ici puis on a rien à pau qui te
fera savoir est au moins aussi gros
coeur que j'habite boue et les deux les
deux font partie des riverains donc
partie des meubles dada grande famille
des chances les trois prises et ça va
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup vous avez
merci vous avez été très gentil de venir
nous voir mario de s'évader serge merci
bonne série maudit on va être sur le
terrain bien sûr nous y sommes vous le
voyez derrière moi viennent sauver
alexandre gascon vous serez nos yeux nos
oreilles vous allez parler aux gens qui
vont entrer parce que là ça commence
arrivé mi aura beaucoup de monde je
commence avec vous dire d'abord dien
bien sûr vous êtes jeune vous avez
beaucoup vers les années 70 the hacker
mais vous l'avez connu lorsqu'il jouait
à
retirer dans les ligues de champions
en fait moi j'ai eu la chance de couvrir
son tout dernier match à montréal et je
parle des anciens canadiens avec qui il
a disputé son tout dernier match en
décembre 2010 et pour ce match
simplement tu lui avait presque seize
mille personnes au centre bell et ça lui
a fait un grand grand plaisir ça lui a
fait vraiment chaud au coeur c'était
ginette reno qui interprétait l'hymne
national à son grand bonheur parce qu'il
a beaucoup de respect pour cette femme
c'est elle qui avait chanté aussi des
nationales à sa retraite à québec avec
les nordiques et il m'avait dit quelque
chose qui m'avait vraiment beaucoup
marqué et m'a dit qu'ils ne peut pas
toujours tout recevoir une rien donné
moi c'est ce qui est vraiment important
pour moi j'ai eu la chance de côtoyer
jean béliveau et il m'a dit c'est sa
façon d'agir et c'est sa façon d'être
qui m'a marqué alors j'ai comme
l'impression que c'est le retour du
balancier c'est sa façon d'agir a été la
fleur qui nous aura tous marquer aussi
très bien alexandre vous êtes de l'autre
côté merci diène a tout de suite vous
êtes de l'autre côté vous allez voir
défiler oui je parlais des dignitaires
mais aussi des ja beaucoup de gens qui
vont vouloir être ici comme ils ont
voulu être au centre bell pour un lit
rendre un dernier hommage
ouais voilà qu'il y aura quelques places
assises pour le public finalement à
l'intérieur pendant la cérémonie une
centaine environ également à des places
à l'extérieur avec un écran géant pour
le public désire est assisté à tout ça
mais oui vous l'avez johnathan des
dignitaires des premiers ministres
messieurs legault et messieurs monsieur
justin trideau évidemment beaucoup de
gens du public un peu à l'image des deux
derniers jours à la chapelle ardente et
vous le savez vous êtes allés sur place
on a vu à quel point l'on voulait lui
rendre un dernier hommage parce qu'à la
différence de monsieur béliveau qui
avait cette prestance la nuance avec guy
lafleur c'est qu'il appartenait au
peuple c'est comme ça que tout le monde
nous la décrit alors c'était très très
très émotif tout le monde était présent
pendant les deux dernières journées pour
aller lui rendre un dernier hommage
défilé devant son cercueil ça a été très
bien fait par le canadien est plus bon
voilà ça ça témoigne de la moe et on le
dit souvent à peu près tout le monde
avait une photo avec guy lafleur on
voyait ce défilé sur une file des
réseaux sociaux des anecdotes à partager
a raconté alors ce que messieurs savoir
les tremblay faisait beau panélistes un
peu plus tôt c'est vraiment ce qu'on a
pu le voir dans les deux derniers jours
l'amour du public à l'endroit de guy
lafleur et tous ceux qui défileront ici
aujourd'hui pour venir assister à cette
cérémonie bien c'en est un autre
témoignage sur certains points
c'est tellement vrai d'ailleurs on a
fait un appel sur nos réseaux sociaux
pour que les gens nous envoient des
photos avec guy lafleur on a reçu une
tonne de photos vous allez mesdames et
messieurs les voir défiler au cours de
la cérémonie déjà on pourrait faire une
émission spéciale d'une journée avec les
photos qu'on a reçu chacun à une photo
et savent où on mesure à quel point il
était généreux il était attentionné et
il se nourrissait je le rappelle se
nourrissaient du public ça pontage pour
lui pierre mondou qui le connu vous
l'avez que vous et vous avez connu les
côtoyer quoi neuf saisons un monsieur
monde où avec lui merci d'être là ça
vous étonne bocquet qu'eric est que
cette réaction populaire devant son
dessin j'ai été piqué sait plus bien que
tout ghilas hull même temps que jean
béliveau et humoriste charles et iggy en
plus avec sommes développés qu'est ce
que moi j'appelle le petit prince je
pense que dans l'histoire du rock il ya
plus d'une dizaine de joueurs qui ont
été comme une vraie bombe et en grèce
qui est beau c'est qu'ils sont eux qui
ont développé ce foot là et guy est
exactement comme un autre ib il était là
hier et euros le carton se ferait du
monde entier et tout le monde l'adorait
il est tellement gentil nico
comme coéquipier parlez-moi tuiles
comment ça marchait ce n'est pas le goff
qui parlait le plus dans une chambre non
non c'était comme je le dis au courant
de la semaine c'est un leader silencieux
c'est bon c'est un leader silencieux
gitta les rebelles vers la lâchant ma
tour dans l'après midi de trois heures
avant tout le monde y est d'allier des
vip lydiane à passer des traîneaux de
standards classe et l'équipement il faut
avec joie avec joie avec ses boutons une
voix piquant qu'on arrivait et a souvent
s'y
expriment ce point gauquie takita
flamboyant c'est un mario tremblay guy
lapointe planète rouge
le fus qui travaillait au temps tout le
monde le sun il arrivait 5h à 20 serge
savard nous on arrivé à 5h était déjà
moody c'était pratique et parce qu'il
voulait se dépasser total il y avait
comme une obsession d'être meilleurs
comme si il ne se voyait pas aussi bon
qu'il était oui totalement travaillant
dans les procès qui arriva même une
dernière place avant tout le monde avec
presque un bon lancer et c'était dans
lui je pense que le le le en plus
d'avoir le talent l'instinct de
contrôler tout ça c'était dans son
coffre d'outils d'être travaillé et je
pense que dans les 3 euros qu'est la
grande marque et des grands super
vedettes et à bastos juste cotonou aussi
piggy c'était un peu des plus
travaillants de l'histoire du rock et
malgré qu'ils avaient un talent en plus
on peut comparer ce prix comme tiger
wood aux cages en plus d'être les plus
talentueux ils m'ont dit que c'est lui
qui plaskett le simon dit que la même
chose c'est une et crosby aussi c'est
pour ça que voir la viande est raccordé
nationale sont autant dans le même jean
françois poirier merci d'être là vous
allez passer la cérémonie avec nous
c'est très important ce que voulait dire
tout le monde ou parce que là il ya des
gens qui ont du talent mais si tu mets
pas le travail ça va pas aussi haut et
guy lafleur avait les deux avait cette
volonté de travail mais vraiment un fond
plus le talent mais ce qui se fait ce
teen ans avec qui la pop y prouver que
vous avez vous en souvenez vous monsieur
monde où c'est que tout à l'heure on
d'écouté sur charente à quel point se
présenter tôt à l'aréna j'avais discuté
avec guettant de faivre et cathy
longtemps le thérapeute de l'équipe nous
départ était pris pour vous un
d'équipements à 17 ans et séduit
couvrait le vestiaire du canadien et
ouvrez le vestiaire et qui couvrait le
vestiaire à guy lafforgue qu'est ce que
faisait qu'il a faim vers 4h30 avant le
match et jouer au backgammon avec le psy
jeunes qui revenaient pas puisqu'il à
s'informer de mots save à l'école alors
va te souvenir guy lafleur dans votre
cas qui fait d'eux au début avec le
canadien finale de la coupe stanley à
boston vous êtes de ces derniers comme
elle vous accueille ighil c'est un des
ces gosses qualité était silencieux mais
tu as eu mal au sommet je sais que ton
juridique ou souvent au courant de la
semaine des as je peux pas me rappeler
qu'aucun conflit avec un joueur dans
l'histoire il était là avec plus de 115
à 84 jamais que je peux définir le
joueur de trouver qui est inconscient
avec higuita super à 120 le joueur qui
arrivait à aucun entraînement et avait
coutume de la force et à la même chose
qu'elle ci par là yvan cournoyer qui est
allé avec lui de toutes ces années
c'était serré quand j'hésite à dos il y
avait tout au tout ce côté là de lui qui
faisait que jouer jouer avec lui c'était
c'était plaisant et souvent ça faisait
un entraînement à faire
un entraînement avec tout le monde
concernant la sélection vous n'avez pas
de soi suivre quelqu'un qui arrivait
dans la chambre qui voyait guy lafleur
réagir comme ça c'est pas une bonne
intention d'essayer d'être car qui est
comme les vibrations d'art qui
connaissent est déçu mais qu est-ce qu
on comprend ce qui c'est dans l'ombre
qui se faisait le plus aimé qu'il a fait
sur ces cinq ans de disette adultes à
lui à plus et a tellement gaullien comme
j'y travaille a tellement fort dans les
pratiques me rappelle toujours le
premier pratiques et les fauteuils
canadien je suppose seulement que lui la
grande majorité des vols du canadien ça
travaille faq un cadeau original souvent
on pense que ça va être assez facile bon
parce que ça on arrêtera ustron
puisqu'on est dans la nasse exactement
le contraire que j'ai vu m'a premier
procès que je m'appelais passe explique
guy lafleur l'italie dont là dedans
aussi gervais et saint poussins à tout
tout les présentes qui présage une
classique ç % pierre mondou merci d'être
venu nous voir sur notre plateau bonne
cérémonie masri bonne suite santé à vous
carla oliviera vous êtes au centre bell
beaucoup d'anciens joueurs comme ce
monde où se rassemblent au centre bell
certains militaires la famille et ils
vont
c'est pas de ses à côtés la symphonie
vont prendre la rue pie
venir sur rené lévesque et qu'ils vont
faire arrivés au fur et à mesure
exactement et je vais vous montrer les
dessous de tout ça parce que oui nous
sommes au centre bell mais aussi donc
sur la rue saint-antoine et les invités
sont transportés dans des autobus donc
qu'il ya quatre autobus qui ont été
nolisés pour cet événement le premier
est déjà parti le premier autobus avec
des invités qu'on a vu monter à bord le
deuxième est déjà installé pour
accueillir donc les gens qui sortent du
centre bell c'est ici donc que les gens
se rencontrent pour partir pour aller à
la cathédrale ce premier autobus a été
escorté par deux policiers à moto et
vous l'avez dit ils en prennent donc ce
parcours qui sera également emprunté par
le cortège un peu plus tard donc il
remonte la rue de la montagne près de
l'avenue des canadiens vont tourner sur
pied et ils vont donc arriver devant la
cathédrale il ya des invités donc
certainement des personnes qui sont
proches de la famille qui vont embarquer
des six autobus vient également d
anciens joueurs dans l'équipe des
anciens canadiens il ya un autobus qui
est réservé pour eux on va essayer de
s'approcher un peu de cet autobus on va
essayer d'aller ramasser quelques
commentaires pour vous donc c'est un
pull et les dessous de cette
organisation que j'essaie de vous
montrer ce matin
très bien car la merci beaucoup les
portes vont ouvrir à 9h30 de la
cathédrale et il ya quelques places qui
ont été réservés pour le public mais je
dis bien quelques places mais derrière
moi on va vous les montre et il y à des
écrans géants et d'ailleurs il devait
faire une journée grise froide ya des
gens qui étaient habillés or le soleil a
fait son apparition et c'est une journée
magnifique sur montréal sur la
cathédrale marie-reine-du-monde michel
lacroix que vous connaissez bien
annonceurs ou des canadiens de montréal
monsieur lacroix bonjour
vous venez pas étonné de voir tout ça
depuis dix jours en faute du tout pas du
tout fou tout triste de voir cette
réalisation ne m'a pas étonné du tout de
voir ces témoignages que l'on a atteint
que l'on voit depuis depuis l'annoncé du
décès dit effectivement il faisait
partie en lob beaucoup de vie de la
famille mais il avait des qualités que
l'on veut tout savoir bavarois y
incarnait le courage la flamboyance la
performance l'attention des autres et
ils disaient que ça les pots avec par
exemple ses patrons il le disait alors
c'est comme si une une honnête
d'absolument une 6ème sincérité jeunes
et aux hits et accessibilité ce sont là
des mots que l'on peut utiliser pour
décrire le caractère de de guy lafleur
réservé timide à la limite mais franc et
du neuf d'une franchise absolument
extraordinaire si j'avais quelque chose
à dire il le disait c'est un homme d'un
seul bloc
c'était comme ça à l'extérieur et sur la
patinoire on a beaucoup dit michel
lacroix qu'il est le dernier
il ya eu maurice richard béliveau il ya
la fleur vous êtes d'accord avec cette
catégorie là un trio absolument
exceptionnel et je me suis plu à le
mentionner on n'annonce pas
maurice richard comme on annonce jean
béliveau et on n'annonce pas dit lafleur
de la même façon ils avaient des
caractères et des personnalités
tellement différent qui étaient pesés
monsieur béliveau contre le racket mais
aujourd'hui c'est qui
ça c'est un petit beaucoup et
qui la fera comptait plus de 5 simple
ouais vous en avez annoncé peut-être la
moitié peut-être juste d'ajouter but
vous a été le plus de vues qui m'a
marqué le plus c'est évidemment ce but
en fin de match on est en 1979 on
affronte blues de baston septième match
honnête offrir montréal il reste une
minute 14 secondes à faire dans le match
et 18 minutes 46 secondes le but fondée
par guy lafleur et des de jacques
lemaire qui a cultivé emmené au but yvon
lambert et quelques temps plus tard le
canadien on portait la coupe stanley
contre les rangers de new york c'est un
moment suivant mémorable longueur
inscriptions yvon lambert pendant 24 ans
j'ai su ce que souhaitait aef qui la
flotte il était la star
on a revu ce but vierge ça donne la
chair de poule encore à chaque point
d'être cédée mama qu'on nous dit pas
mais c'était typique de guy lafleur
quand on ne voyait moi je le voyais
filet sur la droite trappe qu'est ce qui
va faire encore qu'est-ce qui nous
réserve de nouveau les gardiens le côté
les joueurs des équipes adverses
réagissaient de façon qu'est ce qu'ils
vont nous réserver cette fois il lui
même le savez peut-être il n'aimait pas
travailler les jeux comme les joueurs
modernes avec des dessins y avait il y
avait une intuition une intelligence
intuitive sur la glace la plupart de ses
coéquipiers lui en demandait qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour mieux préparer des
séquences de judo on avait rien à faire
c'est la croix je vous souhaite une très
belle cérémonie merci merci les voir en
eux cérémonie qui sera pilotée par
monseigneur lépine que j'ai rencontrée
un peu plus tôt qui nous explique un peu
le cadre dans lequel il veut présenter
cette cérémonie ses funérailles
monseigneur épines merci nous accueillit
nous sommes sur loire à quelques heures
de cette cérémonie en effet comment vous
pouvez la qualifier comment vous vous
préparez à quoi vous voulez qu'elle
ressemble cette série mais pour le
moment je me sens plus comme quelque
chose dans lesquels je suis immergé
immergé dans la tristesse de d'un peuple
de partisans de la famille mais immergé
occident la reconnaissance parce que ces
deux l'occasion de faire mémoire d'une
histoire de générosité
donc je rentre dans cette immersion et
j'accompagne avec les gens et je me
laisse rejoint les tout sépare les uns
donc cette vague d'amour que l'on
semblait semaine dernière vous vous
laisser porter par sur vous vous bénis
de ça absolument je m'imprègne je suis
en mode de se voir absorber et sans trop
savoir où ça va me conduire mais sinon
dans une démarche d'être avec la famille
qui est toujours première mais aussi
d'être avec tout le public qui veut être
ici par vous pour faire mémoire de guy
laflamme et qui veut aussi soutenir la
famille dans sa peine ce sont des
repères et que les gens soient encore
croyants ou pas aux pratiquants ou pas
ce sont des repères ci seront munis l'
importance ce sont des repères parce que
ça nous et la mort de m jour devant une
femme de mystère si on veut on voudrait
que l'ailier continue et qu'on met la
personne et puis là on voudrait que
l'amour aille plus loin mais elle s'est
pas fait c'est pas évident alors on
s'est un temps d'espérance en même temps
que tant de peine et la célébration de
deux fois permet d'avoir les deux
dimensions est ce que quand vous allez
travailler votre discours mais je m'en
fous vous êtes en train de le faire vous
vous vous pouvez vous permettre des
blagues gens au ciel d'un premier trio
extraordinaire mike bossy qui est
malheureusement décédé le monsieur
lafleur il ya d'autres grands joie est
ce que vous êtes vous donné dans
l'univers du hockey aussi
certainement que ça fait partie mais
c'est aussi l'homme alors je parle de la
réalité de l'athlète mais aussi de
l'homme parce que les deux sont présents
dans sa vie il a été l'athlète mais il
ya aussi l'homme qui s'est manifestée à
travers l'arc mais aussi à travers son
engagement même à travers son retour
avec les rangers de new york à l'époque
c'était vraiment une tâche dame ne
serait pas seulement une tâche
d'athlètes là c'était ça prenait du
courage et qu'il a fait donc je me
laisse un rayon de soleil de d'évoquer
tout cela il s'est rien les peines en
terminant très attentionné auprès des
autres pour lui c'était pas un effort
que de passer une heure une heure et
demie à 6000 d 1h30 à signer des
autographes à prendre des photos ça
c'est une qualité qui va transparaître
dans votre dans ce que vous allez dire
sur c'est une qualité de présence dans
ce sens que quelqu'un qui était comme
dans admiré par le public lorsque l'état
devant une personne c'est comme s'il y
avait que sept personnes d'accès club il
avait ce don là exact la présence à la
personne et ça c'est pas si commun et je
pense que ça faut que ça soit
intentionnelle mais c'était aussi un don
qu'il avait il doit fait fructifier
j'arrive du centre bell et de voir tous
ces gens ces citoyens qui viennent lui
rendre un dernier hommage devant le sa
dépouille est quelque chose de très
émouvant il ya comme ça des passes il
faisait partie de notre famille c'est ça
qu'on voit oui on a beaucoup évoqué ceux
qui étaient avec nous il était sur le
terrain dans sa ville natale la statue
de la place les patins sont sur le sol
sont pas sur un pied d'estale donc avait
une idée il voulait être avec les gens
et les gens lui rendait bien ils
voulaient avec lui et monseigneur lépine
je vous souhaite une cérémonie à la
hauteur de cet homme sûr que ce sera le
cas merci beaucoup de nous avons bien su
percevoir par mois
une très belle cérémonie qui se prépare
avec de la musique
très belle musique il y aura entre
autres le requiem je vous le dis de
mozart il y aura des gens qui vont
parler on va vous présenter ça de a à z
bien entendu à compter de 11 heures je
vous le rappelle c'est le début de la
cérémonie à la cathédrale marie reine du
mondial donc les gens commencent à
entrer vous êtes avec les gens qui
suivent le canadien le connaissent bien
le soigneur ou enfin le thérapeute
sportif monsieur le faire
absolument guettant le chef qui a un
vrai à 27 ans auprès du canadien dites
moi pourquoi c'est important pour vous
d'être ici aujourd'hui
baghi a fait patiner pendant 50 ans j'en
ai besoin d'être rouge de connu j'avais
13 ha et il ya joint au tlm en important
le premier temps à d'autres biais même
été au vestiaire très tôt ont joué des
matchs du tableau mais lui et m au
vestiaire toi que 3 heures 45 et 4
et j'avais chauffeur privé qui
s'appelait guide attaquer même chercher
à l'école secondaire à pointe saint
charles les jours de match deux semaines
pour un cap à deauville vestiaires et
puis le temps que moi je me changeais il
y avait déjà mis ses patins ses
pantalons ses jambières l'on joue au bag
est maintenant je jouer au backgammon
avec guy lafleur en 4
cds ça s'invente pas c'est comme sur
réel les magnifiques souvenirs ça s'est
dessinée s'est il était d'une générosité
pas juste de donner mais de dire merci
d'apprécier ce que le petit stade on va
faire pour l'aider parce que guy le
bastia ça son royaume il aperçoit son
stage qui tendent à son royaume des
rites être taxés beaumont et en gagne
j'avais 14 15 ans
on a les immeubles augmente il ya
toujours dans les yeux
puis c'est avec l'adie qui te disais
piste à jerez
qu'il y avait des demandes spéciales
c'était la personne qui demandait le mot
c'est la super vedette la plus sains et
qui demandait le moins
lui demandait il n'aurait de
transparence d'honnêteté puis c'est tout
ce qu'ils demandaient elle m'a amené ici
que j'arrêterai manteau assez chaud que
j'écoute 10cc manteau j'ai tout laissé
seul moyen que j'ai semaines plus tard
j'avais mis quasi de près un pied de
large par speedo je rentre tout peut
changer puis un manteau en outre
jeudi à ottawa depuis sur les tourments
tôt dans mon casier moi j'ai un pied par
six pieds tout le forum au complet
extrême en tout qui me fait plus la
horde pacifiste face à un pied il t'est
jamais faire bien des manteaux en douce
maintiennent de gilgit il a
questionné vous allez garder de guy
lafleur médias je me suis fait un devoir
donner
pays mais je me fie de 14 ans pas je
voulais faire un caca
prennent connaissance de l'emploi
d'individus l'impact qui a eu chaud pas
juste moi même chose ben déjà bien mais
les gens quel impact il aura laissé
selon vous labonté sept chevaux tu peux
être bon mais tu peux être bon sur la
face noire je souhaite bon succès ce que
tu fais de bons aussi dans ton royaume
avec thé avec des pailles c'est bien
important un immortel finalement c'est
un inventaire beaucoup
on me disait
oui merci très très éloquent diane
monsieur lefebvre très éloquent la
beauté ne tue pas merci pour ce
témoignage monsieur lefebvre vous les
voyez défiler je vous le rappelle ces
photos que le public on a fait un appel
nous envoyer on and on and on préfère
une journée entière de diaporamas
d'amitié de mômes à croquer avec guy
lafleur parce que cette cérémonie là
c'est beaucoup la cérémonie du peuple
qui aimait leur idole
parce que leur idole descendait leur
parler comme s'il faisait pire il n'y
faisait partie du peuple aller plus haut
que je vous entendu lors de notre
première émission spéciale merci d'être
l'offre et si j'étais devant le centre
bell puis vous avez vous avez interviewé
par par un de nos journalistes j'ai été
frappé par ce que vous avez dit parce
que vous avez bien résumé vous y est
important pour vous cela ah oui oui
quand c'est une âme c'est 1.14 rock et
commenter les valeurs inculquées aux
peuples moi je trouve que c'est
tellement important fait québécois avec
des racines profondes d'une gentillesse
extrême enfants pensez jamais aussi
s'inscrire urgent d'une neuve que c'est
à son grand ami puis ses deux longues
étapes aux amis pour les fans c'est
parce que il y avait des valeurs
profondes tous les deux il ya main la
vitesse ou
alors ces deux quinze amis c'est
certainement la ram c'est jeannot vous
comme partisan avez vous eu l'occasion
de rencontrer jeunes n'ont
[Musique]
jamais à contrer on a fait un publicité
on et rémy tiff ça pour les plis s'est
imposé une journée complète avec
monsieur guy lafleur avant vos os est
innocent et moi ce rapport il ya
quelques années a fait ou dzsudzsak
siaci les prenais le train de jaser
jeunes à xalapa trop mais oui prenantes
intervention jean alesi fsa ici sur le
parti définitivement en regardant quand
j'ai vu que je devenais à bout ces
épices béliveau peut-être les niveaux
c'est l'échangé c'était pour une tempête
de neige des livres et vous allez me
quels souvenirs vous gardez de l'huile
importée quad monsieur le rat et
monsieur lafleur sellam la matante est
plus grand que son sport on peut dire
c'est les valeurs profondes racines et
ses outrances nation parce qu'il faut
transmettre à nos jeunes peu importe que
tu te fais celum swift au garden et ils
vous êtes peu importe le mythique fait
que les gens étaient riches pauvres
fédéraliste je disais nationaliste il
rassemblait par toulon ou un nouveau
bras nous et quand il ya des franco
ontariens que j'ai vu hier ou sans
abeilles étaient bons sa renommée déjà
c'est bien sûr le québec et au canada qu
aux unis partout partout alors moi je le
fais un très très grand ambassadeur de
qu'il a fallu toute ma vie puis de
gilles villeneuve et à tout jamais je
dois propager ces ses amis ce bloc merci
d'être une force on notait tout ça c'est
mental parler et bien les partisans
jeudi
à dakhla avec un beau changer le musée
mandet tournez-vous sirat ont fait ça
mais tournez-vous de vingt caméras voilà
merci monsieur clos mais c'est sûr et
certain
merci car leur jette avec un ancien joie
aussi
oui alors on est devant l'autobus qui va
amener les anciens joueurs à la
cathédrale on les voit défiler depuis
quelques instants qui rentrent je me
suis levé ici avec moi bonjour monsieur
le bourges c'est important pour vous
d'être ici ce matin où est très
important en tant qu'ancien canadien et
puis avoir eu la chance de côtoyer
guillet à quelques occasions
de lui rendent hommage aujourd'hui pour
moi c'est vraiment important dit et si
la famille des canadiens qui est ici
avec les anciens canadiens aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait je pense que la grande
famille des anciens canadiens des
canadiens c'est une grande famille conçu
c'est serré et puis évidemment guy
lafleur a joué un grand rôle dans
l'histoire du canadien de montréal un
homme qui a inspiré tellement de jeunes
joueurs de hockey et c'est un honneur
que d'être aussi présent aujourd'hui
pour lui rendre hommage avec le groupe
des anciens comment est-ce qu'ils
étaient perçus ben oui c'était un grand
joueur de rock et de toute évidence mais
c'est aussi et avant tout un grand homme
un homme authentique très généreux moi
je les ai côtoyés je peux jouer avec lui
mais je les ai côtoyés dans différents
occasions et c'était vraiment un homme
proche du club on pouvait vraiment
apprécier la grandeur d'âme qu'il était
on va vous laisser embarquer puisque
vous devez partir merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris un moment avec nous avec nous
monsieur lebon
alors comme vous le voyez donc on voit
les ans les joueurs qui sont en train de
rentrer dans l'autobus ils viennent
comme ça par groupe on va essayer de
on arrête un autre pour vous
je voulais réaliser jeunes on vient vous
voir y'a pas de soucis
bonjour bonjour ça va bien mais vous
savez bien un petit mot quels souvenirs
vous gardez de guy lafleur oh mon dieu
mon père a recruté puis à coacher guy
lafleur des années 70 un chic type puis
on se rend compte que c'est vraiment
quelqu'un de spécial parce que on voit
sur les médias sociaux que tout le monde
en photo avec guy lafleur fait que c'est
quelqu'un qui était capable de redonner
sa mère donna communauté puisse aussi un
exemple à suivre pour les jeunes qui
veulent jouer au hockey vraiment une
bonne personne a fait merci beaucoup on
vous laisse embarquer alors vous voyez
tout le monde qui est comme ça des
messages pour guy lafleur on voit que
l'autobus va peut-être partir bientôt on
va le laisser partir patrice
très bien car là tout de suite et ce
sera comme ça il y aura des autobus qui
vont défiler du centre bell qui est un
jet de pierres dit si l'autobus remonte
la rue pie rue de la cathédrale tourner
sur rené lévesque et vous les voyez sur
l'image du coin la cathédrale qui
commence tranquillement à se remplir et
ces photos je vais vous le dire à
plusieurs reprises jusqu'à 14 heures ces
photos que vous nous avez envoyées à
leur merci beaucoup mesdames et
messieurs d'avoir participé à ce moment
parce que ça illustre bien ce qu'ils
étaient monsieur lafleur et jean
tremblay qui est en floride qui avait
des engagements devaient rester en
fleuret d'envoi quand même lui faire un
coucou région bonjour
bonjour patrice mazères s'alliaient pour
les ego qui a rencontré l'enlever pour
aux autres entre eux il s'appelait le
sénateur le bleuet mousse mousse mondou
et je les regarde depuis jeudi revoyant
à 21,25 du bien mais on semble aussi
dansant long mais c'est un privilège
c'est un prix mais c'est passionnant
comme comme l'ennemi
réjean réjean parent que le maire de
québec on va le voir arriver les
dignitaires vont faire leur arrivée mais
reste la région va l'écouter le maire
oui oui et son retour à la fin avec les
nordiques je pense que ça a complété une
carrière une boucle à travers l'ensemble
du québec et c'était fondamental qu'on
soit ici
l'ambassadeur autant pour la ville de
québec pour la ville de montréal dans le
fond ce pour la province au complet qui
la ferait appartient à tout le monde oui
et c'est ce qui est étonnant les joueurs
dans qui souvent ont une carrière dans
une ville elle et les athlètes ont une
carrière dans une ville il
nécessairement mais quand on est à
l'opposé de ces villes ont
d'ailleurs alors qu'ils apportent des
gains du québec de sa ville natale
sursaut de son passage à mauriac était
plus que de leurs yeux mais aussi son
passage à cluses ans avec les remparts
bardon sont passés avec les nordiques il
ya quelque chose qui ralliait tout le
monde capable de rallier canadien
nordiques pour le faire quand même
je pense que son immense capacité d'être
lui même malgré le contexte cette
capacité de répondre avec authenticité
cette capacité doit pas répondre à ce
qu'elles sont les attentes mais plutôt
qui je suis moi et je vais vous le dire
en toute simplicité en toute générosité
mais aussi en toute franchise et je
pense que comme en politique on doit
beaucoup à s'inspirer de ça oui à quoi
vous attendez pour le la cérémonie
votre sanction touchant parce que c'est
le dernier adieu on le dit et je pense
qu'on donne de l'importance de là mais
compte tenu de
l'immense quantité de gens pour qui
c'est important il ya quelque chose
qu'on on est chanceux pouvoir y assister
tout le monde peut donc j'ai
ma chance merci
le maire de québec qui lui aussi a cette
qualité bien sûr je pas de comparaison
ce qu'ils la ferment a cette qualité de
de dire pas mal tout ce qu'il pense
réjean vous l'avez rencontré récemment
fait une entrevue avec monsieur lafleur
pour un documentaire est ce qu'il est et
en paix avec sa carrière est ce qu'il
avait fait la paix avec le départ de
montréal était revenu il avait joué
est-ce que tout seul dans son esprit
était réglé ce qui appartient au père et
jean lui est parti à enfin il ya juste
un point qu'il n'a pas réglé et je pense
que tous les deux hommes ont été pris
par le teint ses jantes le maire les
jantes le maire je l'écoutais ce matin
il était à une station de radio puis
elle le maire c'est le seul point qui
aurait dû insister davantage pour
m'asseoir avec guy lui expliquer que je
joue les pas de mal qu'un évidemment qu
un hit rouille la fin trouve un qui
jouait pas assez souvent puis sur un
coup de tête comme c'est serge savard
qui a pris sa retraite et ça c'est le
direct c'est le seul point guy par
siggers il restait une espèce de zone
ombragée
est-ce que je peux julien point patrice
je suis génial est vite fait ni chaud à
miami pour évidemment c'est le grand
prix de miami la f1 c'est la quarantième
anniversaire
dimanche de la mort de gil 19 et je me
rappelle que j'avais rencontré un
joindre une oeuvre quatre ou cinq jours
après la mort 2009 elle était plongée
dans un dans une douleur à bobigny puis
je pense à lise la peur que ça va ça
fait douze jours aujourd'hui que les
deux bouts qu'elle rencontre des gens
qu'elle accueille les gens avec martin
puis marc ses deux fils et je me dis que
vers 1h 1h30 demanderait le savons
vraiment être fini le présentement est
dans son rôle
elle vit encore l'avis de guy lafleur je
ne sais pas quelle commande quelle
prière je ne sais pas quels mots je ne
sais pas qu'est c'que qui veulent
l'accompagner
mais ça fait 50 ans qu'ils sont ensemble
sont connus en soirée on sont 12 puis
leur peine ça fait douze jours de
suspense et à recevoir des gens puis
douze jours à les accompagner
toujours prête à recevoir les honneurs
du peu de la population mais lise dans
deux ans dans trois heures c'est fini tu
sais je trouve fort
pensée
etc les moments les plus difficiles
c'est après comme tu dis après qu'on se
retrouve seul kalakh à l'adrénaline
retombe alors oui pensée pour sa famille
mais j'ai une dernière question pour toi
est ce que oui il aurait été étonné de
l'ampleur quand même ou wii où ils
savaient
ils sont un peu le ménage ok je vais je
te revient plus tard on écoute hockey
masque vous êtes plus bon sans masque
est-ce que je peux y aller
oui monsieur bouchard dites moi pourquoi
c'est important d'être ici aujourd'hui
il était important pour nous on peut
bien faire je vais dernier mouvement
pour venir le voir c'est quoi votre plus
grand souvenir votre plus beau souvenir
y en a plusieurs guides est à mon voisin
et puis une excellente personne d'une
générosité il était fait un nul blanc
mais jamais pour rien ce qui se passe
sur sa patinoire lui faisaient ce qu'ils
avaient à faire et puis c'est très bon
pour les joueurs qu'est ce que vous
auriez appris de lui
il était très généreux avec toutes ces
femmes ne respect qu'il avait pour ses
fans stephen blake était vrai il prenait
le temps d'aller tout les voir le saluer
si c'est arrivé une couple de fois que
c'est peut-être juste parce qu'il était
fatigué il y avait eu des pressions il
quelque chose
comprenez facilement le déferlement
d'amour qui aujourd'hui huawei c'est
géré par celui du oui ça lui est dur
parce que les gens ont tout un bon
souvenir tout le monde garde un bon
souvenir de dire merci beaucoup je me
passe
et on a pu s'entretenir avec la verra
bensen aussi voici ce que ça a donné
y en a une c'est comme dire
vous avez vu une caisse de bien qu'elle
faisait la meilleure non il ya toutes
sortes d'excellents souvenirs weggis est
un grand ami
c'est un jour triste évidemment
mais il suffit de regarder autour de
voir ce qui signifie pour les gens de
montréal pour tout le monde en fait pour
moi pour mon épouse c'est grand homme
que vous pourriez dire sans français ou
peut-être que toi en espagnol
je vais aller beaucoup de bonne mémoire
de 2 go
quand vous jouez
918 match ensemble il ya beaucoup de
manières même mémoire mais plus que ça
et c'est
gratuit pour cent grâce aussi ils
donnent beaucoup d'heures de les
fondations
et donne son temps à tout le monde
il jamais
pour accepter
signature
incroyable
taille était fou non non mais écoutez il
nous faisait peur parce qu'on était là
on se préparer à sauter sur la glace et
alors là ils pressent combattants
et il donne un grand coup je vous savez
pourquoi je suis inquiet
parce qu'on voulait pas aller à l'école
alors maintenant il faut jouer
personnalité mais une fois sur la glace
était le premier était toujours le
premier là bas 4' ring l'après midi
et il s'est déshabillé
ils avaient été tués et 34 si rld prix
des cafés mais c'était lui il adorait le
jeu
probablement une des plus grandes choses
que bon lui et moi nous avons joué
longtemps parce que nous adorions jouer
ce sport
oui
il va nous manquer il va nous manquer
merci
quel témoignage extraordinaire de la rue
robinson qui nous montre bien le côté
fou de guy lafleur et qui arrive ne
s'est pas à temps et qui en même temps
est très émue d'ailleurs
de ceux qui vont s'adresser dans
l'église qui va donner quelques maux des
joueurs de l'époque qui ont connu les
meilleurs jours du de monsieur lafleur
et du canadien denis bouchard comédiens
vous connaissez bien mesdames et
messieurs qui est un fan fini du
canadien de monsieur lafleur comment
vous devez ça depuis nos jours notre
intuition
c'est doit cesser
c'est la mort d'un beyrouth ceci
dit c'était mon maurice richard à moi
moi je n'ai pas connu les autres mais
lui arrivait dans une conjoncture
historique c'était bien aimé quand le
sang de 16 ce québécois venaient des
lieux 1,96 pour gagner un kopeck lemaire
joueur au monde et ici c'est toute une
époque qui se reproduiraient drôlement
plus et et guy lafleur était
l'incarnation sportive de sa certaine
façon ah oui et profond des mains c'est
ça qu'on voit sur depuis quoi joue pas
un héros oui sur la classe bien sûr elle
nous a fait rêver le courage la
flamboyante mais ce qu'il incarnait
quelques jours et le profond pour la
bâthie et d'un petit extraordinaire car
j'ai fait les cérémonies de fermeture
dudit forum évidemment il y avait tous
les anciens joueurs les sages avaient
tout organisé ça et de chasse y est
d'expliquer aux anciens comment s'était
passée sur le tapis rouge pizzas puis
j'avais pas personne m'écouter
évidemment il tout le monde est content
de se revoir vie de bon et et imite
fermer le forum peace et qui quittent
avenue mohamed bouleghcha robin ce
procès on n'est pas des acteurs mais
quand un mois de sa patinoire puis tout
le monde vote clôt tête de ben ali
cette cérémonie de fermeture du forum
d'ailleurs été le metteur en scène était
si j'ai le goût de pleurer je regarde
très récemment puis la fin c'était les
chaque capitaine remettre le flambeau
mais si on réalise que qui lafleur n'a
jamais été capitaine mais il semblait le
grand leader de cette même oui oui tout
à fait c'est cette stable ici vous a
peut être capitale afghane a qui disent
qu'ils réalisent of the lights mais moi
j'ai pas jamais vu ça mais l'italie de
celui qui disait dans charme même mamie
pour ces cérémonies laïques ok ok ok
quand on vole royal il faudra un ordi
qui rentraient tous en ordre jusqu'à
butch bouchard qui lui déformait tels
faits en bois tout le monde
facebook est ce que il savait vous pensé
parce qu'il savait que ça n'allait pas
bien son concept il savait qu'il était
un ami
je sais pas s'ils savaient mais mais je
sais qu'il l'aimait beaucoup le monde
noir est assez clair il y aura 10 au
centre parce que le mot nude et je vous
souhaite une belle cérémonie
plein d'émotion que ça va être beau puis
on a entendu quelques notes du requiem
et tout à l'heure on va ça va être une
communion ça va être quelque chose merci
interdit de nous voir c'est denis
bouchard il est il est vrai qu mortenson
vous le connaissez les comédiens le
silence des anneaux c'est un fan fini du
canadien aussi on l'a allait me dit on
monsieur martin seulement attendez-vous
à emile à la casquette en plus
bonjour comment allez vous
c'est bien mais
[Musique]
il à faire et mes condoléances à sa
famille mais mais mes pensées mon corps
sont là avec eux et avec goût et et tant
d'autres admirateurs du démon blond
rappelez-nous monsieur mortenson parce
que vous êtes de new york vous avez vous
avez grandi en europe j'avais parlé vous
avez entre autres appris le français
avec la soirée du hockey à l'époque
nous avons nous avons déménagé déménager
dans le nord de l'état de new york mais
mes deux frères et moi avec notre mère
avait après la séparation de mes nos
parents et puis c'était vettel à ce
moment que j'ai commencé à prendre mon
français à aimer le rock & gas aux
canadiens et
gaza guy lafleur
j'ai grandi en haut rang le voyons faire
de l'art sur la glace
exactement faire de l'art sur la classe
et vous avez porté ses palmes est le
champ des du canadien dessous votre
costume du silence des anneaux est-ce
que vous l'apporté encore le dieu et du
canadien
oui et heureusement et le jazzy du
canadien jugé le 10 signé par guy
lafleur que j'ai reçues
lors de la cérémonie de du centenaire en
je me souviens avec du attitude de
l'avoir rencontré on comptait guy
lafleur en ce moment là et basse
ces états
c'était un moment qui m'a profondément
marqué le camp est un peul
saison le talent les talons l'élan et
l'humanité de cet homme
sont irremplaçables
c'est tellement vieillit le cas là les
là et l'humanité de cet homme donc pour
vous
c'était quelques saints artistes là
c'est quelqu'un qui vous touchait
profondément
[Musique]
n'oubliez
irremplaçable pour moi et
mes bas il était elle était un lieu pour
moi et il le sera toujours
mais on vous êtes le bienvenu à montréal
et ça lui nous si vous venez lui rendre
hommage au québec vous allez vous avez
un film vont vous êtes à vancouver je
crois vous tourner
le dernier film dans lequel vous avez
joué avec david cronenberg je crois sera
à cannes
voitures ces derniers
don
devant 23 au 24
mai on va voir
on voit on aura la première de ce film
et puis on va aller au canada je crois
que toronto et puis à montréal si
oui quoique bon bah les amants à là pour
faire la promotion
marie-claude que vous connaissez bien
notre chercher sa vaillante rechercher
ce qui faisait rejoindre vancouver ça
sera un plaisir de vous reparler giteau
moorkens martens merci beaucoup de nous
avoir parlé c'est très apprécié
merci à la prochaine
marcel aubut qui a parlé il ya quelques
secondes on s'en va l'écouter on revient
tout de suite
il y en a plusieurs je posais 4 avec lui
2 un jouet puis deux ans dans les
bureaux alors on était proche et à
meilleur souvenir quand je tenais à new
york que convainquent de sa mairie
québec je pense
y avait 6 1 amélie était prêt à le
renouveler pour l'année à suivante à
nous nos vidéos ce cas c'est la 6e place
entière plus joyent à kaka montréal il
va venir finir ça dans la ville qui
l'adulé avec les rapports tout ce qu'ils
avaient fait avant d'aller dans l'hymne
national alors j'ai convaincu puis une
frappe était trop dur
quand j'ai dit ouah c'est aussi 2 1 dans
les bureaux avec nous autour de quatre
ans les voyez ça quand même une espèce
de sécurité mais mon dieu qu'est tf1
puis c'est gentil
respectueux il ya
quelqu'un qui appréciaient ce qu'on
faisait pour lui même des petites choses
très petites choses alors ça c'est un
événement marqué pour moi est avec lui
ben mahi bine l'autre j'ai fait beaucoup
de promotion avec lui pour les nordiques
et mario sentier ii qui est décidé
maintenant est un autre moment là c'est
sûr quand je recevais des décorations
qui a sauvé des trophées encore jetés là
alors le thème je connais bien famille
alors
tout ça c'est ça me donnait méchant coup
pareil on savait que ça allait arriver
parce qu'il était vraiment malade et à
chaque fois de boyet je voyais gonflé
comme une vraie bonne note un crime il
reste pas grand temps puis avec blizzard
a parlé au nom de la respiration musique
par les analyses plus vite cette
saison comme ça adios énoncés par car
vraiment le puits avait décidé souffrir
jusqu'à la fin a noté as révèle plus
saab et des méthodes d'aujourd'hui pour
raccourcir sa potée sens s'il le bat
oria
bataille à face est encore une
possibilité
de mailing j'apprends dans cet
équipement a lui aussi pris au sommet
est-ce que c'est le symbole d'un compte
d'un québec des complexes
monsieur marcel au but qui rappelle
d'abord comment la mémoire qui est la
plus importante pour lui comment il l'a
convaincu de la québec pour la fin mais
qui dit surtout allaient tout faire il
s'est battu jusqu'à la fin avec courage
devant ce cancer des poumons d'autres
dignitaires ont parlé on les écoute on
vient
alors mon commentaire mais
les grands joueurs mac leur sport
les idoles marquent leur peuple je pense
que c'est ce que c'est ce que guy
lafleur refait pas seulement marqué son
équipe pour son spa même marqué la
mémoire et l'histoire du peuple
québécois donc ça va marquer des but au
paradis maintenant puis
je très content lundi pour les airs au
revoir une dernière fois
voilà graphane le chef de québec
solidaire cochet grand fan de hockey
jean fraçois ve vous revenez sur viggo
mortensen est grand je veux sujet le
match du centenaire à montréal en 2009
la manière par laquelle viggo mortensen
avait présenté qui la ferait le démon
blond le numéro 10 l'éternel qui la
flore et je pense qu'ils avaient bien
choisi le mot l'internet qui travaillent
messieurs charrette avec diana
lui remettre l'ordre national du québec
en 2005 j'avais été beaucoup
impressionné par son humilité et sa
générosité et toutes ces villes a été
comme ça que y'a pas des québécois pour
ceux qui l'approchaient et est donc
aujourd'hui on célèbre pas uniquement un
athlète mais vraiment un homme qui a été
pour nous
exceptionnel vous avez dit qu'il
incarnait tout ce qu'on attendait dans
heroes c'est un peu ça oui pas parce que
d'abord comme athlète était un niveau
que très peu d'athlètes peuvent
ce père est atteint là-dessus ses
performances étaient et ça nous rendait
très fier hollande est très fière comme
comme québécois et canadiens de le voir
sur la glace mais après sa carrière il a
aussi été très disponible généreux il
était plutôt réservé mais est un homme
très humble mais et ça aussi ça nous a
beaucoup marqués je pense que les
québécois ont beaucoup apprécié l'an ils
nous ont tous marqué comment ils vous
ont marqué moi je les ai vus jouer les
remparts de québec 15 à sherbrooke il
n'a sherbrooke avec les remparts il
remplissait le palais des sports de
sherbrooke chaque match des remparts de
québec à ce moment c'était l'équipe
junior et il jouait contre les castors
de sherbrooke alors qu'un il venait au
palais des sports on se prépare est
toujours le pire mais mais ils étaient
les premières fois je l'aï vu jouer été
spectaculaire on voyait de suite que
c'était un athlète qui était au dessus
des autres non merci beaucoup c'est très
bien car là est avec un autre athlète au
dessus des autres qui est maintenant
entraîneur du canadien
carla avoue
martin st-louis bonjour bonjour
c'est quoi que ça représente cette
journée pour vous aujourd'hui
je crois c
ces derniers chapitres de
la célébration de guy lafleur qui mérite
ça a été
le chemin est difficile pour les frais
d'organisation le peuple à parme et l'as
roma
je suis vraiment content de voir le
respect qu'on lui donne
et se sentent devenus ajourné le tout le
monde qui ont passé sur nous et merci à
guy puis aujourd'hui c'est un deuil en
tenant moins d'avoir la chance d'être à
son suffrage
le pouvoir
tant partition dernier chapitre vraiment
les remercier de montrer du respect
qu'ils méritent pas jusqu'aux joueurs de
hockey mais comme humain et représente
pas juste du canadien tu peux alors ça
naturel d'avoir des funérailles
nationales pour guy lafleur se sont
énormément c'est un c'est un homme qui a
eu tellement d'impact
soudaine
j'ai beaucoup d'expérience génération je
prends mon père mon passé ce sont
meilleurs joueurs souvent favoris
pro-cnt tandis qu'un strict et
chapeautée long que chez veste et qu'il
appela ses piquants guy est décédé je
parle à mon père c'est la journée avait
là mon jeu
et mérite ce hobby quels souvenirs vous
allez garder de lui
pas moi c'est les cheveux dans le vent
les cheveux dans le vent la maison mère
iliad l eau claire
9e le regard le
caractère comme si je voyais le cac
prenant modèle des fois la touche en a
l'air
les cheveux dans le vent puis le
savey keith ana lelas va être l'attitude
que je vous envoie ce jugement va
compter le but je m'en veux aider mon
équipe c'est
quelque chose qui est inspirant
merci beaucoup martin st-louis
les cheveux dans le vent c'est une belle
image
jean-françois une belle image que martin
st-louis emploi c'est tellement de
personnes se souvient de pasqua jugé
mois patrick walsh
dans la série mais rapidement les
cheveux dans le vent ont de vue tout à
l'heure johnson très ému en voyant un
jeu de la rue robinson en finale la
coupe stanley contre boston c'est en
prolongation il fait là parlent sur le
flanc la flamme des cheveux dans le vent
le lancer faire pays quand le canadien
gagne tout le monde derrière le filet et
là c'est une image sera temps de l'amour
de ses coéquipiers pour la flore ses
cheveux dans le vent de ce sommet
bravo la chef du parti libéral qui a
parlé à quelques secondes et enrico
ciccone trop émue a toujours en les
costumes
c'est appâter aujourd'hui puis il appela
aujourd'hui c'est physiquement y est
parti mais il va vivre je mêle
baisse et elle a mis tout le monde s'est
elle émue tout le monde qu'il a fait
c'est une personne qui était tellement
projet j'ai se voyait dans la rue
étaient plus grands que nature mais en
même temps tu es tu as porté vers lui
c'est ce qu'il a fait puis c'est pas
tout le monde qui sait tout rôle mais
lui il avait pas ce qui les attire ces
gens là avec sa simplicité
mais comme un grec comme un ami comme un
membre de la famille je pense que c'est
comme ça qu'on qu'on retient ce qu'il a
fait arrêter pour le peuple québécois
pis ça a dépassé les frontières c'est un
idole au niveau du canada aux états unis
également c'est un grand joueur qui a
laissé sa marque pas seulement comme
joueur doit quelques amateurs mais comme
personne
merci
voilà une ré coach icaunais qui sait de
quoi il parle aussi hockey et qui je
vous le rappelle je le disais tout à
l'heure était tellement émue toujours on
lui a parlé qu'il y avait de la
difficulté à parler pendant qu'on voit
des images larry robinson lui aussi très
émue pas très croire ledit va parler
lors de la cérémonie un autre qui va
parler c'est jeff molson qui est
accompagné de diane
monsieur mon unique le canadien perd un
géant aujourd'hui on vit un deuil
collectif mais pour vous il représentait
quoi guy lafleur il représentait les
canadiennes montréal parfaitement il
nous représente aussi dans la communauté
parfaitement c'est un joueur qui que
j'ai apprécié quand j'étais très jeune
mais c'est l'homme que j'ai connu après
sa carrière qui a beaucoup fait pour
tout le monde dans cette population on
l'a ressenti beaucoup d'émotion à
l'annoncé de son décès de votre part
dites moi qu'est ce qui vient vous
chercher c'est trop tôt on a perdu trop
tôt c'est quelqu'un que j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps avec puis j'étais pas
prêt pour le jour vous avez fait appel à
patrick roy pour qui elles prennent la
parole aujourd'hui dites moi pourquoi
c'est important pour vous non c'est
important on veut que ça ce qu'il a fait
arrêter quelqu'un qui était adorée par
toute la population à la ronde et des
coéquipiers mais on veut de la prochaine
génération de vedettes qui représente
aujourd'hui aussi vous aimeriez que vos
joueurs actuels retiennent de la façon
de faire de la façon dont va être de guy
laflamme j'espère qu'ils vont lire les
journaux
cette fois c'est fait ils vont voir un
homme qui est dédié à sa communauté un
homme qui était un winner un excellent
coéquipier puis il ya beaucoup à
apprendre de guy lafleur il vous aura
marqué vous
c'est quelqu'un qui est passionné 1 et
un sens d'humour extraordinaire c'est
beaucoup versez
une image extraordinaire mesdames et
messieurs vous voyez en direct je
tremblais et patrick roy comme si le
message qu'on veut les envoyer en les
plaçant côte à côte dans l'est sur le
banc de l'église c'est qu'on enterre
toutes les chicanes on enterre toutes
les chicanes du passé on se réunit dans
la joie pour dire adieu
aux membres le plus illustre de l'équipe
donc carey price je crois est avec carla
on va aller voir carla tout de suite en
direct qui est avec le nôtre gardien de
but on écoute
aujourd'hui absolument
évidemment c'est un grand jour
monsieur lafleur va laisser un impact
non seulement sur l'organisation mais
sur le québec et aussi sur eux tout le
canada
je les ai rencontrés à plusieurs
reprises ou et
canadiens ont toujours très bien réussi
à faire venir leurs anciens j'ai eu
plusieurs fois l'occasion de les
rencontrer
il m'a toujours traité avec beaucoup de
courtoisie de respect
c'est un grand représentant de notre
organisation vous n'avez jamais joué
avec lui au contre lui normal ce n'est
pas mais je suis content de pas avoir eu
contre lui mais
il avait grand talent et non seulement
ça mais j'avais aussi un grand
leadership et pouvait vraiment traîner
l'équipe
jusqu'à des résultats glorieux il a été
un très grand représentants d'autres
organisations
quels souvenirs devrions nous engager
c'est un homme de grande classe un
modèle pour les jeunes canadiens les
joueurs il a toujours traité les gens
avec beaucoup de respect c'est un grand
représentant merci beaucoup car presse
un modèle un modèle dit carey price
toujours avec le bon ton respectueux
envers la personne avec qui il parlait
yves tremblay qui est avec moi vous êtes
amis vous êtes écrivain vous êtes en
fait j'avais écrit l'homme qui a soulevé
nos passions guy lafleur bonjour ah non
non pas du tout moi je suis l'auteur du
livre les plus belles maisons ce qui
valut à 2035 écrit sa biographie bon je
photographie aérienne bon ben il ya un
souci gg sous volet le québec avec ti
très bien alors racontez moi des
souvenirs glam l aviation absolument
c'est un pilote d'hélicoptère et on se
rencontrait souvent lors de galas et de
super fondation on offrait des tours
d'hélicoptère et qui comme copilote et
il était très généreux de son temps et
il était apprécié de tous les confréries
des pilotes d'hélicoptère et on avait un
projet ensemble qui était d'aller dans
le grand nord ans semble retrouver des
grands chefs des premières nations dont
je suis issue et on vous voit vous êtes
il nous oui on vous voit avec lui c'est
l'hélicoptère d'abord c'est très
difficile qu'un avion et il l'avait sens
commun que gilles villenave le ce goût
oui voilà se dépasser deuxième carrière
donc dans l'aviation ça demande beaucoup
de concentration que d'aller voler donc
ça le ca l'animait beaucoup et il était
vraiment heureux quand qu'il volait il
aimait aussi partagé il ya même amené
des passagers derrière et venir voler et
montrer ses beaux paysages qui nous
entourent hockey et je profite de votre
présence pour dire que ce qui est
peut-être moins connu du grand public il
est allé en afghanistan invité par
bagotville lors des trois fois trois
fois ils avaient trois tournées il était
colonel honoraire des amis de l'aviation
des forces canadiennes il était le
président d'honneur de l'association des
propriétaires d'hélicoptères du québec
il était reconnue dans le domaine de
l'aviation et par l'armée canadienne il
est beaucoup de ses confrères
lieutenants colonels et généraux qui
sont ici aujourd'hui noyade est
exactement on va les voir si vous voyez
mesdames et messieurs déjà en habits des
militaires ils étaient prêts très
respecté par la communauté militaire
canadienne par ses gestes très concret
ils y allaient 3 soit magmatique je
travaillais désolé de vous avoir
rebaptisé
1,18 qui parlent ces trois hélicoptères
griffon qui vont passer à la sortie
juste pour le saluer à très très basse
attitude alors soir tout un spectacle
merci beaucoup merci monsieur tremblay
marc isabel rochât je le dis depuis ce
matin c'est d'abord et avant tout pour
le public des gens ordinaires qui seront
aussi qui sont ici pardonnez moi vous
êtes avec quelqu'un qui en a qui tenait
à être là très tôt ce matin
oui il s'agit de pierre ils vont pelti
il s'agit d'un photographe qui a
travaillé pendant 33 ans au journal de
montréal photographe sportif qui a connu
guy lafleur dès le début de sa carrière
première fois qu'il a photographiés
c'était en
1968 et justement c'est ce que vous
m'expliquiez racontez moi justement ces
premiers instants ses premiers moments
quand vous l'avez photographies sur la
glace qu'est ce que vous en avez passé
un premier temps il faut appeler rapport
de québec chine à montréal pour des
parties de hockey alors les découvrir à
partir de là avec un coup de patin
extraordinaire
les cheveux blancs en vain
alors c'était quelque chose de le voir
qu'un qui est arrivé à montréal
lancement des offres que canadien le
repêcher oui j'ai commencé ma carrière
au journal de montréal
alors c'est sûr c'est là il me suis lié
d'amitié avec guy et à partir de là je
n'ai jamais lâché pendant 40 heures
pendant 40 ans dont vous avez eu quand
même une relation privilégiée avec lui
vous l'avez suivi à différents endroits
vous avez aussi publié un livre
là-dessus qu'il à faire la légende mais
tellement j'aimerais j'ai penché de
publier un livre dealer show là les gens
parce que les gens aiment mon année
après ses meilleurs joueurs au monde des
années 80 la mais que c'était un
privilège pour moi de l'avoir comme ami
quand même et puis guise était
généreuse gala je faisais des photos
que par cette affaire tellement aller
avec lui il jamais non c'était trop rui
que celle ici mathieu s'étaient tous la
même affaire c'est vrai on peut dire
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je touche à
tresser marée de le voir partir
on aimait beaucoup impôts jugement qu'il
aime l on voit ici le chandail rouge on
n'a jamais vu le numéro 10 lafleur
c'était en tout cas je suis bien content
que
d'avoir été son ami pendant 40 ans merci
beaucoup à l'art pierre qu'ils vont
payer photographe sportif pendant plus
de trente trois ans qui a suivi guy
lafleur pendant une bonne partie de sa
carrière
merci beaucoup
jean-françois
je reviens secondes sur l'image de
patrick roy puisque quand même dans
l'histoire du canadien c'est quelque
chose l'image de patrick roy avec avec
son ancien coach ne se sont pas parlé
pendant des années ils sont réunis sur
un banc dyckmans qui le ferait et et
rassemble jusqu'au bout jusqu'à ses
funérailles et j'ai aperçu pas ma convoi
marque bergevin l'ancien directeur
général du canadien mais j'ai aussi
aperçu joe sakic joe sakic son équipe
d'avalanche que le redoux lés le
président-directeur général entame ses
éliminatoires ce soir il a fait de choix
donc d'être ici aujourd'hui et joe sakic
a fait ses débuts donc dans la ligue
nationale alors que guy lafleur porté
l'uniforme des nordiques alors c'est une
marque de reconnaissance de la part de
joe sakic l'un des meilleurs joueurs de
l'histoire des nordiques et de la ligue
nationale la ministre des sports du
québec parler on l'écossais
s'est passé on a commencé
avec avec ma famille regardez leur qui
ma soeur qui était une grande fan de ken
dryden moi c'était plus guy lafleur
je pense que c'est le symbole de tout
est possible et qu'on peut rêver qu'on
peut
on peut fracasser des robes des records
alors pour moi si c'est un
nikon c'était une grade est incroyable à
quoi vous attendez de la cérémonie
aujourd'hui or beaucoup d'émotion je
pense que c'est de dire au revoir ou
adieu
quelqu'un qui nous a fait rêver qui nous
a donné tellement de satisfaction de
fierté donc ça va être très très émotif
et et avec une énergie aussi incroyable
je pense que tout le monde qui serait
l'oeuvre
d'yves à venir va vivre un moment
privilégié de pouvoir c'est lui
guy lafleur c'est un gars de chez nous
un gars du québec j'ai regardé les
matchs du canadien quand j'étais petit
avec mon père ma mère mon frère on était
petit des femmes de voir guy lafleur
valley sur la patinoire avec ses cheveux
au vent je pense que tout le monde a été
marqué par ces bus
évidemment il ya inspiré toute une
jeunesse aussi aller voir leurs acquis
mais vers d'autres ports qui a réalisé
crs a montré que les gens du québec on
était capable d'accéder au plus haut
pour dire fracassé des records donc
c'est vraiment un moment très important
et émouvant ici aujourd'hui pour
l'ensemble du québec et pour moi aussi
évidemment
siemens annonce
alors voilà oui
il rassembleur jean-françois c'est
exactement le bon mot jusqu'à mario
tremblay et patrick roy ça va être une
photo qui va rester on à monsieur savoir
à qui honda parle en tout début
d'émission mais on va aller le réécouter
bien sûr
guy a été géré été chanceux et
malchanceux d'arrivée acteur canadien
parce qu'il est arrivé avec macha sur ce
qui est arrivé qu'une bonne équipe
malchanceux parce qu'il ya partir de
seulement 28 but au lieu de 50 66 avait
joué aux clients de cette époque il y
avait des gars comme yvan colonna y ait
quitté presse à la première vague du jeu
de puissance il était chargé de tomber
avec une bonne équipe puis 2 3 3 à plus
tard y est devenu le meilleur joueur de
la ligue nationale par la france quel
sentiment vous habite toujours
et quand tout le monde on est en
nitrites
on le savait de plus longtemps mais ça
change quoi la tristesse qu'on a même si
on sait que ça va arriver un moment dan
il devrait savoir si vous arrivez mais
dans son cas lui il y avait arrêté des
traitements
on avalanche et vécu une dizaine de
joueurs la journée de son 60e
anniversaire
puis c'est une journée convoite aussi
rappeler longtemps parce qu'il est sur
le thème un plaisir de parler des
anciens souvenirs il m'a donné il nous
parlait de situation puis quand tu as
pleuré puis deux minutes après tout le
monde souriait pourparlers accorde des
bourses ont mené puis mais tout le monde
savait que c'est notre note daniel
l'enjeu qu'on avait avec dj conscience
aussi et à combien il ne vient pas
directement ça va tous cette journée des
italiens avec earth et de ses deux fils
m
[Musique]
heather
et jamais eu joaillerie ce tissu h et
reliant guînes à l'instar de maurice
richard jean béliveau est toujours fait
bientôt tu es un gars d'équipé s'est
jamais sentie plus gros client a
toujours été c'est c'était un grand
grand superviseur
il y était
que des humains qui était particulier il
a fait une différence pour tout cas pas
aussi de fait la différence après sa vie
sur la glace et finit premier comptage
était le meilleur joueur de la ligue
pendant six ans après sa carrière
l'a fait à quatre choses dans les
derniers les derniers mois de sa vie à
fait l'avis de forme pour le chef ramos
et au delà de 2 millions et sa femme
d'isère coria il m'a dit mais c'est pour
moi comment profiter il ya d'autres
personnes qui va profiter c'est un peu
ce qui est écrit merci monsieur ça va
oui d'autres en ont profité pour se
savoir le répète souvent il transcendait
bien sûr son sport il a fait une
différence une différence partout où il
est allé diane à un invité
y en a une autre on sait jamais mais
à oued et subissait le remplacer car
alors des guy lafleur comme veut dire
exceptionnel un joueur exceptionnel un
homme exceptionnel
on dirait que tout le monde travaille
sur le connais tel tout le monde a une
histoire
et moi j'ai joué avec des rapports
passés à côté et puis
lorsque gitte avec les nordiques mon
père est décédé à north bay en ontario
et marcel aubut nolisé un avion guy
lafleur et puis sont venus aux
funérailles de mon père à north bay en
ontario alors certains autres qu'on
écoutait reportage que fait souvent et
moi je les ai vécus et puis c'est sodie
lafleur
andorre
en dehors de la patinoire
à quel point il me faisait remarquer
vous mais moi il m'a marqué beaucoup
parce que j'ai joué avec je joue avec
des remparts je te sais côté je tape un
peu nerveux c'est un gars calme et puis
travailler
les souhaits mentionné le dépouillent
depuis que l'histoire montcenis oui un
gamin tanins mais exploités sont année
au maximum il a peut-être dépassé
quoi parce que une grande grande fierté
pour les partisans pour l'équipe pour
lui-même et la passion et puis je les
admire et j'ai continué ma part j'ai
toujours une admiration pour la plage
pour toutes ces raisons que je viens
mans series alors les côtes on suppose
qu'ils vont avoir un autre convive
alors qu'on voit monsieur trudeau qui
fait son arrivée ce trudeau son père est
un grand fan de guy lafleur avait
assisté souvent au match on va l'écouter
merci pour ces émotions qui nous a fait
vivre en tant que joueur en tant qu
inspire à sion tous ces bulles qui nous
a donné
mais aussi ce moment pour le remercier
pour sa profonde humanité
la façon qu'ils étaient au service de
nous tous en tant que québécois et en
tant que canadiens jeu
tellement
touchée par sa vie aujourd'hui suivi une
journée à réfléchir à tout ce qui nous a
amené tout ce qui continue de toutes les
façons pourquoi nous nous inspirer de l
homme d'une grande sensibilité de
chaleur humaine je les rencontre et
quelques secondes à la mon adolescence
c'est l'état qui était dévoué à aider
les jeunes et très dévoué aussi en tant
que père en tant que personnalité
publique à caen c'est qu'on sent la
cause la santé mentale ce qui est
tellement important alors on célèbre son
courage sa sensibilité
these days
aujourd'hui c'est le moment de remercier
guy lafleur
pour tous qui nous a donné
pendant toutes ces années toutes les
victoires toute l'inspiration les
parties incroyable et qu'il a joué mais
aussi sa profonde humanité
sa contribution au monde autour de lui
et légendaire est une inspiration pour
nous tous aujourd'hui c'est le moment de
réfléchir et de célébrer s'il nous a
donné
monsieur trudeau qui souligne ses
qualités humaines les valeurs qu'ils
incarnaient les qualités qu'ils
incarnaient et qui donc était une
inspiration pour pour les gens pour son
père je le disais on a eu ces images
dans votre documentaire
jean-françois ou que vous avez présenté
à rdi vous avez déniché à peu près
toutes les archives possible et il ya
des archives de monsieur trudeau ou
forums wikis trip est passé moi
l'expression avec les joueurs est assis
derrière le banc des joueurs du canadien
qu'une fois la coupe stanley gagné
contre les rangers pierre trudeau était
allé faire un taux est lui aussi avait
eu droit à la douche des vainqueurs oui
tout à fait donc monsieur trudeau yabo
il ya beaucoup
de bons les premiers ministres sont là
mais ce logo va faire son entrée
monsieur trudeau vous venez de l'entente
j'ai vu monsieur couillard faire son
entrée tout à l'heure il monsieur
charest qu'ont entendu et il ya madame
marois donc qui a parlé qu'on va écouter
vrai héros et puis les peuples ont
besoin de héros puis on a raison de le
reconnaître comme tel c'est un homme qui
était passionné par son métier une
passion telle qu'il allait dans la
chambre des joueurs avant beaucoup avant
que je ne commence que la partie ne
commence et j'ai toujours pensé que dans
la vie on ne faisait bien ce que l'on
faisait que si on le faisait avec
passion puis dans son corps il avait un
talent et non mais pour fournir finir je
vous dirais que c'est un homme généreux
donne de son temps assez à ses fans
évidemment mais aussi à la société dans
laquelle ils vivaient et souvent vous
savez les plus grands sont les plus
humbles et c'était son cas et c'est pour
ça que je suis ici ce matin une source
d'inspiration qui dépasse de beaucoup le
sport oui absolument on le voit
d'ailleurs son rayonnement dans les
fondations dans l'aide qu'il apporte à
des jeunes l'autre aspect qui pour moins
aussi important c'est le fait qu'il a
amené des jeunes sûrement à part ça
pratiquer le sport finalement que six
ans belle kino sport national on
aimerait ce qu'on soit petit peu plus
nombreux comme francophones chez le
canadien de montréal mais cela étant il
a eu un impact dans sa société plus le
fait évidemment c'était un homme
généreux qui a adhéré à des causes
importantes
je sais plus tôt
alors voilà madame marois qui dit on ne
fait bien que ce que l'on fait avec
passion et je pense que pendant qu'on
voit monsieur trudeau qui fait son
entrée à la cathédrale marie reine du
monde on voit monsieur coderre qui salue
donc madame trudeau et voilà
marie-josée marc isabelle rochon vous
êtes avec des gens du public du marbre
du public qui
commencent à s'accumuler autour de la
cathédrale
mais écoutez il ya quand même plusieurs
une plusieurs dizaines de personnes tout
le long de la rue ici je me trouve
justement j'ai rencontré deux femmes
deux femmes qui s'appelle civique se
sont rencontrés justement ce matin et
qui sont venus quand même de loin et
donc vous êtes venu quand même de
sherbrooke vous avez pris congé de votre
travail expliquez-nous pourquoi c'est
quelque chose qui se raisonne pas
moi j'ai vu là j'ai eu la chance de voir
guy jouer chez les remparts de québec
parce que je suis originaire de québec
c'était le chao mais aussi de mon frère
après la game de hockey il ya les los
ché cendrillon le reste de la poule la
basse ville à québec aussi belloc était
omniprésent chez nous bien sûr mon par
un fan fini des canadiens puissent à
jouer en noir et blanc mais qui séparent
sa personne sa simplicité allier une
certaine classe qui nous rejoint
beaucoup mais je remercie beaucoup
donc c'est ça on voit plusieurs dizaines
de personnes centaines de personnes qui
sont ou le long des clôtures qui
regardent justement les écrans géants en
ce moment et ça continue on continue de
voir déjà arrivé
très bien merci merci beaucoup oui à la
foule qui grossit on va l'écouter jean
perron qui est là sur le parvis
vous sentez aujourd'hui
ouais quand
j'étais un peu comme guy lafleur je suis
passionnée par l'art qui il a acquis
suscite des passions qu'aujourd'hui de
quand je vois tout ce mondial je me dis
ça cause de guy lafleur jean béliveau
maurice richard on est tous comme ça ici
au québec tout le monde est passionné
vous regarde à lille téléjournal est
salée les partisans c'est dans notre adn
la passion qu'on a provoqué au québec
soit à cause des gars comme guy lafleur
faut cinq à son côté ségolène tu as fait
vibrer pourquoi que moi je suis devenu
un entraîneur je voulais devenir un jour
à la une ne serait-ce à cause de gueule
comme ça ça fait que c'est ça la passion
tout le monde est passionné au québec
courant qu'ils l'assument super
un autre grand fan de hacker ou l'avait
vu arriver le premier ministre monsieur
legault par un convoi les joueurs
actuels du canadiennes montréal qui font
leur entrée sur le par jean victimes et
ce pour toute la fierté qui nous a donné
ça a quand même quelque chose
de décès un dino qui est le meilleur
joueur de hockey au monde dino qui est
le meilleur joueur de hockey au monde
quelle fierté il nous a donné à toute la
nation québécoise dont qui mérite
amplement des funérailles nationales
puis on lui dit merci pour tous les
moments de bonheur qui nous a donné
pendant toutes ces années l'eau puis
pour tout aussi sa proximité avec les
québécois étaient vraiment l'un des
nôtres et vous prononcer une allocution
aujourd'hui non je laisse s à ce qu'ils
aient l'ont connu personnellement
malheureusement je n'ai pas connu
personnellement donc je pense très
important que ses amis nous en fasse un
peu plus connaître sur eux sur l'homme
décomplexés
effectivement la stap quelqu'un qui
avait à langue de bois c'est ça que les
québécois apprécient étaient
authentiques qu'il disait ce qu'il
pensait au risque d fois de se mettre un
petit peu dans le trot ou de se faire
quelques ennemis mais au fond tout le
monde l'aimait parce que justement
c'était un homme vrai
oui effectivement
c'est un défi partout dans le monde on
le voit aux états unis on le voit en
europe réunis toute la population puis
on le voit le
anglophone francophone les gens de
toutes les tendances politiques
bah ils sont tous derrière guy lafleur
donc il y aura réussi quelque chose de
grand de réunir tout le monde pour n'est
ce pas que ça va inspirer à plusieurs
personnes pour la suite des choses
yes yes
we je pense que nous sommes tous fiers
aujourd'hui et nous sommes ici pour dire
merci à la fleur
il était le meilleur joueur dur que nous
étions fiers qu'un type bien d'ici soit
le meilleur joueur de hockey au monde
et il a eu un
réussi ces derniers jours à rassembler
tous les québécois
à les
réunir
[Musique]
soutenir ce que nous sommes et pour dire
notre fierté à propos de lui
[Musique]
en direct
n'essayez pas de faire des phrases
creuses c'était un homme sincère et je
pense que tous les québécois l'apprécier
il disait ce qu'il pensait il était un
teg il était direct ça revient beaucoup
depuis deux jours ce commentaire la de
sincérité et c'est pour ça donc qui
connecté au teint avec les gens un
joueur gilbert perreault qui est super
héros merci d'être là vous avez vous
avez bon je les ai malheureusement pour
jouer avec le canadien mais vous avez
une carrière extraordinaire que les
arbres vous souvenir remonte aux juniors
avec monsieur lafleur vous oui c'est un
69 3 juin inclus lui dit alors on est à
notre équipe est un peu plus forte que
celle des rapports cette année nommé se
sont repris l'année d'après en gagner la
coupe mémorial alors on se fie depuis ce
temps l'on ne trouve où est un conte
lahoud et seule fois qu'on ne voit
ensemble juste avec team canada où il
saisit un cadre européen et ensuite de
suzhou environ 815 avec lui dans l'ailé
les fangio qu à travers le canada c'est
le revers on l'a appris une sonnette et
puis c'était ce début d'année parce que
je tiendrai adverse bien c'est après que
vous avez pu renouer dans cette équipe
de décevoir l'avez vous une grande
compétition entre autre fléau car
convenait montréal un état trop juste un
joueur canadien français qui était ce
utile tous les gars vous connaît déjà la
french connection
les années précédentes puis il y avait
rené robert qui joua
qui étaient des gens professionnels à 18
est alors réuni 3 lorsqu'on venait à
montréal bien sûr c'était on essaie de
faire au match de rejet qu'est-ce que
quel homme vous avez connu après
qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé dans cet
homme là guy laflamme vous voyez là
toutes les réactions aujourd'hui lisa
bonbons avec le public généreux avec une
longue très longue moi j'ai vu ce que
leur signer des autographes besoin
d'atteindre une joute de hockey et puis
après un crime ajouté ces tapis je
rétorqué puis donna son nom au public
de nombreuses parts si la tournée des
légendes à travers canada en entier
puisse vous me disiez c'est un peu grâce
à guy lafleur lui tenait à ce que cette
tournée là et lieu parce que il ya mais
cette somme il voulait être avec vous au
créer cette ambiance me
fait ch d'aider les familles tout cas
tous sont à l'air il a far east est la
cause de tout partout très populaire
jusqu'à 1 à l'asco rooney va rouler
dit a connu d'autres partout alors c'est
en apprenant têtes d'affichés
publicitaires se traîne à 30 que fait
beaucoup pour les légendes
donner son temps avec nous autres et
puis c'est grâce à lui que les gens ont
douté et ont eu beaucoup de succès ce si
beau avoir joué avec lui à coupe canada
lacc réuni gilbert perreault guy lafleur
c'était le choc des juniors mais enfin
vous étiez ensemble ce souvenu se
souvenir de coupe canada par des moyens
oui en 80 j'ai eu la chance de jouer et
puis worsley et puis ce fut un beau
tambourin promène
c'était c'était plaisant de voir que
c'est double double de grand talent et
puis l'animent et à face et le jouer
sur une note plus personnelle en
terminale s vous avez eu l'occasion de
lui parler de communiquer avec lui dans
les derniers mois dernières années j'ai
parlé environ grenet
il m'a appelé parce que sa mère avait eu
des problèmes de santé on se parle de
sous et puis
c'était la dernière fois qu'on s'est
parlé puis j'ai gagné deux leaders et
c'est très positif que aujourd'hui la
médecine on sait jamais ce qui peut
arriver
ça peut il pu sortir sains miraluka
chaque jour de la médecine d'alors
j'avais dit un super positif puis quitte
à fond comme un cheval guitare ou sans
sursis en tout cas il s'est battu
jusqu'à la toute fin merci beaucoup
monsieur bayrou demis le plâtre est très
apprécié par un convoi mesdames et
messieurs c'est là qu'on voit ce cortège
qui va s'ébranler vers la cathédrale
marie reine du monde avec derrière la
famille qui vont les membres de la
famille qui vont prendre place dans la
cathédrale je vous rappelle que bien sûr
on réjean tremblay au début de
l'émission nous en parler de sa femme de
ses deux fils qui laisse dans le deuil
il laisse dans le deuil également sa
mère pierrette ont eu la chance de
rencontrer à thurso au dimanche carette
qui à 90 ans madame lafleur pendant
qu'on voit donc le corbillard qui va
transporter le cercueil et la dépouille
de monsieur lafleur c'est tout près donc
du centre bell où ça a été
vraiment un flot continu du public
depuis dimanche 11 heures il ya eu du
monde hier midi on est allé avec une
équipe et je suis allé après faire le
tour avec les citoyens s'attendent à
quoi une heure et demi à peu près et les
gens ce qui était beau se racontaient
leurs souvenirs les gens se parlaient
des gens qui se connaissaient pas et
tout au long donc de la tente ça
devenait une grande conversation
publique avec un homme qui rassemblait
tout le monde monsieur lafleur avec des
photos avec des souvenirs
alors monsieur jeff morrison qui est
avec le grain patron porte parole et les
premiers ministres de
du canada oui on a qui excusez moi hein
on à patrice brisebois complet à
l'écouté je crois
patrice brisebois commente comment tu as
été marquettois par guy lafleur mais guy
c'était mon idole de jeunesse c'était le
le joueur que quand je marque un but
bien quand j'étais jeune j'ai levé mais
bronze à 15 heures c'est le but marqué
par guy lafleur la première fois j'ai vu
guy en actions j'avais pété 10 ans 11
ans et c'était compter sans le beauf
l'occasion a marqué 5 à 2 guy avait
marqué deux buts
alors je t'avais revenu à la maison puis
jetée comme tellement tellement heureux
par la suite la suite j'ai eu la chance
de le côtoyer avec les anciens canadiens
il a été mon entraîneur de l'équipe de
balle molle j'ai passé une semaine avec
guy en afghanistan on peut aller
supporter les troupes là-bas alors j'ai
tellement de beaux sonné avec du monde
plus beau souvenir c'est quand qu'on a
fermé forum de montréal et il fallait un
joueur actuel et un ancien et c'est moi
qui ai sorti avec de la fleur du forum
alors
ça remue beaucoup de souvenirs et
d'émotions non beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup quoi qu'est ce qu'ils viennent
chercher là dedans mais c'est un idole
son idole puis il ya tellement
de témoignages qu'on a entendu des
dernières semaines
thénot grangeot ce
thème un bel hommage tellement
un goût unique
authentique sincère
oui attendu y ait beaucoup et
beaucoup qu'est ce qui te ra a pris deux
pattes de guy lafleur
la relation qui avec son public c'était
si ce texte extraordinaire je les ai vus
à des matchs de balma signer des
autographes pendant deux ou trois heures
super de la clôture puis siens jusqu'au
date dernière personne alors si c'est si
ce qu'on dit authentique tu peux pas tu
peux pas avoir plus sains que ça tu peux
pas
c'est un homme là whaou merci beaucoup
beaucoup appris beaucoup appris de lui
on est mal ils vont me manquer
la patrie ce but qu'a t-on quand on
parlait de modèle ce modèle d'être
respectueux avec le public et il
attendait pas ses revenus depuis deux
jours ils attendaient jusqu'au dernier
des citoyens qui voulaient une photo qui
voulait un autographe
c'est de loin la vedette ici au québec
qui gagnent le plus d'autographes depuis
les trente quarante dernières années oui
on a vu que gary bettman donc la ligue
nationale il ya dépêché des gens
importants bien sûr compte tenu de
l'importance jean-françois oui beaucoup
de personnalités présentes aussi du
monde artistique et adore j'aperçus
claude meunier avec il avait présidé la
campagne de financement pour
le chum je crois mais claude meunier a
dit une phrase intéressante à son sujet
c'est lorsque j'ai croisé guy lafleur
pour la première fois c'est la même
impression que j'ai eus que lorsque j'ai
croisé paul mccartney oui en effet
qu'avait la fleur sur des artistes aussi
une des chansons d'écrites qui faisait
un lien on a entendu le plus loquace
quand je bois aussi daniel
boucher oui le but guy lafleur
66 alors se voyait 24 fossé de guy
lafleur qui secoue tout le temps car à
convoyer le cortège qui va arriver d'ici
quoi 5,6 millions devant la cathédrale
marie-reine-du-monde michel bergeron a
parlé on les côtes lundi
du journal autre pays je me dis toujours
ce pour
ce trop jeune partir
c'est là
il paie très c'est ça qui est
souvenir qu'on va garder c'est que
c'est un gars qui étaient toujours au
dessus de la mêlée mais sa part sa peau
était tellement authentique
je suis content je les coacher après
avoir
véhicule la rivalité avec guy
gelé coaching et du couloir là qui est
devenu qui devenait mis sa j'oublierai
jamais seul
assesseur
c'est sûr
[Musique]
non
vraiment défaite à peu près les mêmes
choses on ne compte avait dit du racket
jean béliveau maintenant c'est flou
c'est top c'est le vise c'est plate je
pense à alice qui a été avec lui depuis
ses années juniors si ça bouge à
semaines je faisais à comparer avec mike
bossy qui a connu sa femme à 17 ans à
laval piggy qui reconnut lise
adultes 9 ans à québec
des
badauds quelqu'un qui est venu avec les
rangers d'avoir été plus âgés que les
autres joueurs donc la complicité cfb sa
femme était allée speg ma femme
michel bergeron qui est très ému on l'a
attendu la journée de l'annnonce du
décès de monsieur lafleur très ému
monsieur bergeron qui il a bien dit
c'est devenu un ami oui a été son
entraîneur oui il ya eu toute la période
à new york mais c'est devenu un ami des
gens très proches et souligner quelque
chose qu'on n'a peut-être pas assez
souligné depuis toujours c'est bien
jeune soixante dix ans pour partir en
effet le cancer leur rattraper son père
à monsieur lafleur était mort d'un
cancer du poumon également monsieur
lafleur malheureusement avait cette
mauvaise habitude de fumer puis la fumée
très long tall jusqu'à
récemment jusqu'à il ya quelques années
et ça pardonne pas malheureusement ce
cancer l'a alors bref oui c'est bien
jeune on retourne dans la foule marc
isabelle rochon
pour parler à quelques personnes à
queens vous pendant qu'on voit la salle
d'un 5 6 minutes le cortège devrait
arriver devant la cathédrale
oui et on dit que guy lafleur a vraiment
marqué des générations donc non pas
uniquement les personnes qui l'ont vu
jouer sur la glace mais aussi des
personnes plus jeunes et je me trouve
justement avec trois jeunes de 20 ans
qui ont tenu à venir le voir aujourd'hui
à la première max et moi pourquoi c'est
important de vous déplacer aujourd'hui
premièrement t
comme vous l'avez dit on a juste valeur
le jamais vu jouer mais
c'est un gars qui est vraiment marquis
l'équipe en tant que tel le club mais
aussi le québec au complet puis juste
dans la culture québécoise une icône
tellement importante pour toute la
nation fixe pour ça que c'est important
pour nous d'être là parce que même on en
a rêvé qu'on était jeune puis c'est un
exemple à suivre pour tous les québécois
dans les générations à venir
pour moi glisse et c'est un modèle même
si on l'a pas vue comme mon ami a dit
c'est quelqu'un qui a expliqué le
québécois erik guay charismatique une
bonne personne puis
c'est important pour nous de venir même
si on le connaissait pas et vraiment on
l'a beaucoup vu nos parents nos grands
parents d'en parler beaucoup c'est
important de venir quand même aussi
bien de la france c'est quelqu'un qui
m'a qui imagina puis comme est comme mon
ami entends tu le dis même sont
appauvris jouer c'est comme quand
j'étais petit puis je jouais au hockey
dans la rue c'est le numéro 10 dans le
dos puis on se prenait pour les icônes
comme jean béliveau et guy lafleur pis
c'est pour ça que je trouve important de
venir aujourd'hui parce que c'est un
gars simple stenger qui était proche du
peps un gars avec qui ont plein de
personnes par exemple ont déjà vu mais
je connais bien passé même si on n'a
jamais vu jouer mais qui le rend compte
qu il prenait toujours le temps de
discuter de
discuter des problèmes une nouvelle qui
nous écoutent et donc c'est pour ça que
je trouve ça important de dire un
dernier au revoir à guy commande ou
qualifier ce qui se passe si le faisait
dans la foule il ya tous ces dignitaires
qui passe on les voit pas assez comment
vous qualifiez l'homme ça montre
vraiment l'importance puis l'impact qui
dit lafleur
sûr
l'entièreté surbaissement au québec en
fait on voit des politiciens des joueurs
de hockey actuelle des anciens un des
joueurs des mets police qui était leur
excès vraiment un gars qui était
apprécié de tous puissions nous tous à
venir rendre un hommage à guy lafleur
comme tout le monde ici avec nous puis
comme nous l'a fait
merci beaucoup les gars très apprécié
alors comme je le disais justement donc
guy lafleur qui a vraiment marqué des
générations même si c'est trois jeunes
qu'on a rencontrés ne l'avait pas vue
jouer ils ont tout de même tenu à venir
à lui rendent hommage aujourd'hui
très bien pendant qu'on voit l'arrivée
du corbillard et du cortège à la
cathédrale vous allez voir des officiers
du service de police de la ville de
montréal et de la sûreté du québec un
habit d'apparat qui donc dirige le
cortège il ya trois limousines de la
famille qui vont s'arrêter pendant qu'on
va écouter les applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
je
vous avez entendu les guie guie guie la
folle là qui atteint qui retient presque
son souffle en attendant de voir le
cercueil alors que le corbillard est
arrêté devant la cathédrale
et limousines dépose la famille de
monsieur lafleur lit son épouse dont on
a parlé tout à l'heure qui après c'est
les moments difficiles c'est après quand
la foule est partie quand elle était là
depuis dimanche 11h à recevoir les
condoléances des gens au centre bell
avec martin son fils donc le fils de guy
et marque son autre fils
la mère de monsieur lafleur et les
soeurs de monsieur lafleur sont
descendus de thurso ce matin sa mère à
90 ans pierrette
qu'ils nous disaient qu'elle ré mais
elle est changée de place
rien de pire pour une mère que d'aller
enterrer son fils
et la famille qui tenait aussi est ce
que le public puisse assister à led
écran géant devant la cathédrale à la
cérémonie en direct il ya quelques
membres du public qui ont pu entrer à
l'intérieur mais très peu
c'est lise non pas son époux sam et la
soeur de monsieur lafleur que l'on voit
entrer et c'était son autre soeur juste
avant
et une cérémonie je vous le dis qu'ils
vont nous frapper par l'émotion droite
au coeur avec un choix musical
vraiment très approprié vous allez voir
si vous n'avez pas de frisson vous
n'êtes pas l'humain je crois
jean-françois le la présence du public
bongo est important dans l'esprit de la
famille et un esprit monsieur lafleur
oui ici un silence qui règne selon elle
depuis quelques minutes on l'a accueilli
avec des gui gui gui qu'on va sûrement
encore entendre
et
c'est très émouvant
ce qu'ils ont beaucoup aimé affaire on
ne l'a pas beaucoup aimer tant aimé tout
coup
[Applaudissements]
il
ce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
et
[Musique]
oh
c
[Musique]
oh
et
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
et
mais
[Musique]
au nom du père et du fils et du
saint-esprit
la paix soit avec vous
vous êtes venus nombreux en présence
dans les médias
nous sommes réunis pour entourer de
notre affection de notre sympathie dans
notre amitié
ceux et celles qui sont dans la peine
je pense particulièrement à lise
épouse de guy lafleur
ses enfants mark
martin sa conjointe
ainsi que sa petite fille si anna rose
à sa mère pierrette
assesseurs
il ya toute leur famille ainsi qu'aux
nombreux amis et coéquipiers de guy
lafleur
je salue cordialement
monsieur le premier ministre du québec
monsieur le premier ministre du canada
monsieur le lieutenant-gouverneur
madame et messieurs les premiers
ministres
madame la juge à la cour suprême du
canada
monsieur le président de l'assemblée
nationale
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame la chef de l'opposition
officielle et messieurs les chefs du
deuxième et troisième groupes
d'opposition
monsieur le chef du bloc québécois
monsieur le chef de l'assemblée des
premières nations québec labrador
madame la mairesse de montréal
et mesdames et messieurs les élus
municipaux
mesdames et messieurs les députés
sénateurs et ancien parlementaire
tommy soldes nationaux drogue et ligue
senior executive orders en préservant
les propriétaires et président d'
équipes
du club de hockey le canadien de
montréal
distingués invités
son imminence cardinal gérald cyprien
lacroix
nous voulons affirmer ensemble tous ces
liens d'amitié d'affection que nous
tissons tout au long de notre vie
que nous avons tissés avec guy liés
qu'ils ne savaient pas avec la mort
avant de poursuivre la célébration
liturgique
je vous invite en temps des témoignages
qui vont maintenant vous est adressée
venez vous asseoir
bonjour mesdames messieurs
c'est un privilège pour moi de vous
présenter ce qu'ils témoigneront de leur
affection aujourd'hui envers guy lafleur
tout d'abord le propriétaire président
et chef de la direction du club de
hockey canadien de montréal fera honneur
à son actif
jeff
dans la dernière semaine
nous avons été témoins de
l'incommensurable influence que guy
lafleur a eu sur un grand nombre de
personnes au québec dans le monde du
hockey et dans toutes les communautés
dans lesquelles il a été impliqué
son impact a traversé trois générations
de partisans des canadiens de montréal
il y a eu ce qu'ils ont vu son
sensationnel talent à l'oeuvre sur la
glace sont les années 70 et 80
et puis il ya eu les enfants et les
petits enfants de ses partisans qui ont
eux-mêmes a pris la grandeur de guy
lafleur de leurs parents et grands
parents
il ya aussi eu les millions de personnes
qui ont eu la chance de côtoyer cet
homme passionné et dévoué à sa
communauté
que ce soit en redonner redonner aux
hôpitaux
ou autres grandes causes
en supportant les militaires en mission
à l'étranger
ou en aidant les enfants d'en voir dans
le besoin qui lafleur était là
c'est cet homme leguil affaire que je
connaissais le plus la personne
chaleureuse et généreuse qui l'a été
après sa carrière
qui vous écris est cool guy était aussi
passionné de son rôle comme ambassadeur
du canadien de montréal
quand nous demandions un guide nous
aider dans nos missions communautaire
qui l'accepté toujours mais ça n'était
que le début pour lui
quand guy lafleur rentrer dans une salle
où s'ouvraient les caméras prenez des
seules filles et les gens cherchaient
tout de suite un bout de papier un stylo
pour obtenir son autographe
et
il n'y a jamais eu d'occasions où tout
le monde dans la salle n'est pas eu
droit ce selphy à cet autographe
tout le monde repartait après avoir vu
ses attentes satisfaite mais guy avait
encore un plus grand impact que cela
dans la salle parce que les gens
découvraient qu'il n'était pas seulement
une superstar un joueur du panthéon du
hockey mais une personnalité
humble simple normal avec un énorme sens
de l'humour quand les gens lui poser des
questions à propos de sa grande carrière
il racontait volontiers des histoires à
raconter des blagues et rillettes avec
des gens qui ne connaissaient pas la
minute d'avant un homme qui avait du
temps pour tout le monde
les gens repartent avec le sourire mais
avec un souvenir spécial de quelqu'un
qui allait toujours plus loin pour tout
le monde
je pense que la raison pour lesquelles
les gens du faisait confiance c'est ils
vous disaient exactement ce qu'il
pensait il ne prenait pas de détours il
ne recourrait pas aux formules toutes
faites il disait clairement ce qu'il
pensait et il parlait du fond du coeur
et son quart était passionné
quand il parlait il sentait ce qu'il
voulait dire et parfois ces commentaires
est un difficile à accepter mais ils
avaient généralement raison toujours
franc et c'est ce que les québécois
aiment particulièrement propos de guy
lafleur
qui représentait les canadiens de
montréal parfaitement
il était un gagnant sur la glace le
meilleur joueur dans la mer avec et pour
montre sans comme individu et comme
coéquipier il n'était pas différent en
dehors de la glace un être humain
incroyable un joueur d'équipé pour le
bien des communautés qui en avaient le
plus besoin
nous avons perdu l'un des grands de
l'histoire des canadiens de montréal et
il ne sera jamais remplacée
mais nous avons également appris
beaucoup de guides un homme avec de la
classe et une humilité qui faisait
oublier la célébrité et le statut de
vedette qu'il avait son approche 1 avec
tous et chacun peu importe qu'ils
étaient est une leçon pour nous tous
je suis honoré d'avoir pu apprendre de
guy lafleur et serait inspiré pour
toujours parler merci pour tous qui
membre du temple de la renommée est
gagnant de 10 coupes stanley même robe
entière
le capitaine thing capte le numéro 12
membres doivent yvan cournoyer
la famille du site d'arak et des
canadiens a perdu une grande légende
un homme qui aimait son public
et son public les maires aujourd'hui
c'est un honneur de vous parler guy
lafleur mon ami
je n'ai pas eu la chance de voir
jouer guy j'ignore
mais la première fois que j'ai vu guy
sur la patinoire avec nous
ça m'a vraiment impressionné
ça me fait ça fait voir ça va faire tout
un joueur de hockey quel bourgeois qui
va tête
merci sam pollock
d'avoir repêché guy lafleur ça nous a
permis nous les joueurs et les
spectateurs
d'apprécier par un plusieurs années est
de gagner cinq coupes stanley
pour toute la famille de guy
surtout lice
martin mc
madame la fleur des dernières années ont
été très utiles en
lice
guittet mais beaucoup
je suis certain qu'ils taux réduit de te
reposer
les soit forte et courageuse
la décision de prendre sa retraite est
très difficile à accepter
surtout à 31 ans
nous abandonnons ça qu'on aime le plus
dans la vie c'est d'être un joueur de
rock et
c'est pourquoi j'ai appliqué dès fois
s'informer commence qu'il allait je
voyais que la décision de prendre sa
retraite l'affecté beaucoup et on se
parlait j'ai passé par là moi aussi tu
parlais souvent un moment donné et
vendredi je l'appelle des digues et
comment savoir
ça vaut bien vidéo biez bat deux fois
mais dit ça vaut bien
ici il va et
chaabi kebab emma b les voitures
suiveuses il ya je l'avais ma voiture
et 10 trois fois deux fois
trois fois
alors l'homme cela parce que
guy
c'est le second qui va laver sa voiture
trois fois c'est à guy lafleur alors je
n'étais pas surpris qu'il fasse un
retour
guy nous a laissés trop tôt
mais s'il veut faire un autre retour
serait la bienvenue guie guie guie guie
membre du temple de la renommée est
gagnante de six coupes stanley même
laurent kg fame parts de famille big
three sixty nine stanley cup championnat
le numéro 19 mon but martin larry
robinson
[Applaudissements]
c'est un honneur
de me tenir devant vous aujourd'hui
hommage à une personne très spéciale
je pourrais parler pendant des heures
sur les jambes redéposer qui était guy
mais je pense que vous vous tous ici
savait déjà à quel point il était une
personne incroyable
dit adieu aux jo joue à chaque jour
comme si c'était la dernière
[Applaudissements]
et non seulement que la jouer chaque
match au maximum mi mai il a également
reçu sa vie au maximum au dos la glace
je tiens à vous remercier tous d'être
venus aussi aujourd'hui enfin que nous
puissance tout célébrer la vie de cet
homme incroyable
c'est un honneur et un privilège pour
moi d'être ici devant vous pour rendre
hommage à une personne irremplaçable
dans nos vies je pourrais parler pendant
des heures de cette personne qui est
aiguë mais je pense que vous touche vous
savez à quel point cet individu est
incroyable il a dit un jour faut jouer
chaque partie comme si c'était la
dernière
personne n'a mieux incarner cette
philosophie que guide lui même et non
seulement il jouait chaque partir au
maximum il a vécu sa vie au maximum en
dehors de la patinoire je vous remercie
tous d'être venus aujourd'hui pour que
nous puissions rendre hommage à la vie
de cet homme extraordinaire
oui nous avons perdu de grandes
personnalités ces dernières semaines
mike bossy et guy lafleur succombé au
cancer
j'espère
qu'il ne cherche pas de défenseurs là où
tout de suite
membre du temple de la renommée est
gagnante de trois coupes stanley et
autant d'autres faits franck ce même
broker oppenheimer
france est chauffée
champions le capitaine tim capte le
numéro 21 membres twenty one guy
carbonneau
c'est un réel plaisir pour moi d'être
ici ce soir aujourd'hui pour rendre un
dernier hommage à guy lafleur qui était
une personne spéciale c'est un joueur
qui est extraordinaire tu te fait faire
des choses sur la glace qu'on aurait
tous rêvé de faire
mais ce qui le rendait vraiment spécial
c'était comment il faisait sentir les
gens autour de lui il inspirer les gens
qui l'entouraient et les fait se sentir
important je fais partie de ceux et
celles que guy a inspiré j'étais un
jeune garçon de 11 ans nie à sept îles
quand guy lafleur a fait ses débuts avec
les canadiens et c'est devenu comme la
plupart des jeunes de mon âge mon idole
instantanément mes amis moi voulions
tous imiter guy lafleur il était dans
une classe à part il disait ce qu'il
pensait il joue à sa manière et c'est
pour ça qu'on l'aimé tant il faisait
ressortir le meilleur de ses coéquipiers
il fallait être à son meilleur pour
suivre son rythme
quand je suis arrivé au premier camp
d'entraînement avec le canadien j'ai dû
me pincer
dès les premières journées on m'avait
jumelée avec ce tee shot et guy lafleur
de mémoire je ne crois pas avoir touché
la rondelle qu'une seule fois la part
des savoirs
mais j'étais sur la glace avec mon idole
de jeunesse
sega l'a vu naître gagné quatre coupes
stanley et guy venait de remporter leur
cross le conn-smythe le trophée hart en
plus d'avoir été nommé au sein de
l'équipe de toit de la nationale à
plusieurs reprises et malgré ça ils
étaient là et faisait tout en son
pouvoir pour que je me sente à ma place
c'était ça guy lafleur un super star
mais aussi où on est deux boys
c'était l'une des personnes les plus
généreuses et accessible que j'ai
rencontrés même après avoir pris sa
retraite lorsque nous allions de ce que
nous allions dans l'ouest pour jouer au
hockey avec les anciens ou qu'on joue au
savoir l'été à travers le canada les
gens faisaient la file pour le
rencontrer il prenait toujours le temps
nécessaire pour tous et chacun il était
réelle menace réellement fière de
représenter les canadiens de montréal il
a mené par l'exemple et a établi un
standard pour ceux qui le précédaient
aujourd'hui nous disons au revoir à une
légende nous perdons l'un des plus
grands joueurs marquez et ambassadeur
que notre sport est connu mais nous
perdons également un ami merci pour tout
ouïe
membre du temple de la renommée
gagnant du trophée jennings à cinq
reprises et du trophée vézina à trois
occasions il a remporté quatre coupes
stanley
je n'ai
fait que le numéro 33 nombreux friterie
patrick roy
dans les années soixante dix tous les
gens joie d'arc et du québec rêvait
d'être un guy lafleur moi je rêvais
d'être un ken dryden pour pouvoir un
jour jouer dans la même équipe que guy
lafleur guy c'est un joueur plus grand
que nature dont les exploits et les
poubelles prouesse n'avait pas de
limites
c'était l'idole le héros l'inspiration
est la preuve vivante qu'on peut qu'on
doit rêver grand
en 1984 quand j'ai franchi les portes du
forum et que j pl il le corridor pour me
rendre au vestiaire en vue de ma toute
première pratique avec les canadiennes
montréal j'ai pris toute la mesure du
héros qui se dressait devant une stature
de la prestance du ker ys
le numéro 10 établi à 5 minutes
intimidé impressionné je vivais un
moment sur rés
avant de sortir il m'a donné un coup sur
les patrimoniaux et le kid bienvenue
chez les canadiens parce que c'est ce
que guy lafleur c'est du coeur un
profond respect et de la générosité sans
borne
si le gore qui prend atteint parce qu'il
sait que pour toi ces quelques mots ont
fait toute la différence
c'est sa façon de dire que maintenant on
est dans la même équipe qui va être là
pour toi même si votre ajouté dessus
non-stop dans les prochaines minutes
notre affrontement le plus mémorable
remonte au 4 février 1989 alors qu'ils
faisait un retour au jeu cette fois dans
l'uniforme des rangers de new york
c'est aussi son grand retour au forum
dès l'échauffement la folie they had et
les escales de son nom une soirée
magique tellement magique que kane au
score et de vue j'ai reçu une ovation
ce soir là j'ai vu un héros revenir à la
maison retrouver ses partisans et
recevoir cet immense dosdat mots avec
beaucoup d'humilité
ce soir-là ce héros a même trouvé le
moyen de relativiser mes erreurs et de
lancer des fleurs à ses ex coéquipiers
ce soir là au forum on a tout ce qui est
dit à quel point il nous avait marqués
des années plus tard alors qu'il était
au centre vidéotron pour tourner une
publicité il est venu me saluer et a
pris le temps de jaser
comme il l'a fait dans le vestiaire en
1984 c'était sa façon de venir donner un
coup sur les bases d'un an si
c'était sa façon de prendre soin des
siens de nous rappeler que même si on
n'est que de passage dans une équipe
l'appartenance l'amitié la fierté perdue
bien au delà d'une saison de hockey
depuis l'annnonce de son grade et pas
les éloges se multiplient et clairement
la moitié de la population du québec à
une photo avec guy lafleur parce que guy
c'est aussi ça une générosité hors du
commun
infra parler et de l'authenticité le
respect profonde défense ce souci de
redonner de s'intéresser réellement à
l'autre et de près cet instinct qui fait
toute la différence
je peux vous dire que même nous les
anciens on l'a notre photo avec guy
lafleur on a à capsules et ce au moment
où il a pris le temps où il nous a
écouté conseillé
ou soutenus comme pour se rappeler qu'au
final c'est l'équipe avant tout
guy car je me replonge dans ses
souvenirs j ai dit ce que notre relation
aurait été à l'image d'une game de
hockey de trois périodes marquantes
comme coéquipiers comme adversaire sur
la glace et commencé
devant lever des masques et crée ton
départ j'avoue que j'aurais bien pris
une prolongation
mais je comprends que tu gaza pour le
moment au
au délà des statistiques des prouesses
et des exploits au prend aujourd'hui
toute la mesure de son legs et des
valeurs de coeur qu'il soit insufflée à
des générations
repose en paix mon ami tout le monde ici
ce qu'était un vrai
bon on rend hommage à guy martin lafleur
accompagnée de sa tante francine barré
[Applaudissements]
tôt dans ma vie je me suis rendu compte
que j'avais un père exceptionnel en tant
qu'homme il y a tellement de choses que
j'admire chez mon père si elle qui me
vient tout de suite à l'idée c'est qu'il
a toujours pris soin de sa famille
malgré ses nombreux engagements
il aimait beaucoup être avec nous
je me souviens qu'à une mam nay au forum
pendant les pratiques du canadien ils le
faisaient aussi avec les winger et les
nordiques
mon père était peu démonstratif mais
chanter toute la fierté qu'il avait
peut-être avec moi il voulait que je
fasse partie de son équipe
je me souviendrai également de sa
persévérance non seulement au hockey
mais aussi dans les différentes sphères
de sa vie
il était fier de nous même dans les
moments difficiles que nous avons
traversés la famille il était derrière
nous en nous rassurant par ses gestes et
ses bons mots il a toujours toujours
voulu le meilleur pour ma mère pour mon
frère est pour moi
vous dire que mon père était généreux
est une évidence il a été également pour
sa mère et ses soeurs en fait il voulait
prendre soin de tout le monde même des
gens qu'il connaissait pas
je vous dirai aussi que son humilité m'a
toujours impressionné il est resté lui
même malgré toute l'attention qui
gravitaient autour de lui
j'apprécie tellement avoir été près de
lui que ce soit comme partenaire dans le
milieu des affaires tu as les parties
d'or qui qu'on a joué ensemble avec les
anciens canadiens ou simplement en
famille à la maison sur le bord de la
piscine même quand ils brûlaient les
hamburgers sur le barbecue à toutes les
fois et blanc maire bien évidemment le
barbecue
gym il est un bon souvenir et je
pourrais vous en parler longtemps
mon père n'était pas parfait mais il a
tout fait qu'on soit heureux et qu'on
manque très
il a tout donné à sa famille à ses fans
et c'est accompli à travers ses deux
passions car effectivement il en avait
deux leur hockey et piloter un
hélicoptère
merci pour toutes les valeurs que tu ne
transmises dan notamment
avant de céder la parole j'aimerais
remercier tous les partisans qui ont
appuyé mon père du début jusqu'à la fin
vous êtes merveilleux merci beaucoup
j'aimerais également remercier le
canadien de montréal qui nous a soutenus
à tous les niveaux vous nous aidez à
tous les jours à monter montagne qui
semble insurmontable
merci beaucoup
finalement j'aimerais remercier le
gouvernement du québec qui en or mon
père comme joueur acquis mais aussi
comme un être humain merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je fais partie de la
belle famille de guy et j'aimerais lui
rendre hommage
mais avant il est vrai de dire que
derrière tout grand homme il y une
grande fan je voudrais saluer la force
et le courage dont lise fait preuve
durant ce dur combat qui la traversaient
les gi lise ton accompagnement durant
ces longs mois a été cinq étoiles bravo
ma soeur
pour revenir à guy
on peut dire qu'il a vécu sa vie comme
il a joué au hockey avec passion avec
détermination avec fougue il parlait de
ses tripes c'est pour ça que les gens
l'aimaient et nous aussi d'ailleurs
en fait il n'y avait pas de barrière
entre lui et le public
je peux vous dire que pendant les
cinquante ans que nous avons fait partie
de la même famille il n'est jamais
arrivé qu'on puisse manger au resto ou
aller à quelconque endroit sans que
quelqu'un lui demande un autographe
et c'est toujours avec la même gratitude
envers les gens qui lui manifestait leur
affection qu'il signait non sans
adresser quelques mots à chaque
personne rencontrée
on pouvait reconnaître lettres généreux
qu'il a été
j'ai souvent entendu des discussions
autour du hockey est unanimement les
gens revenaient toujours au fameux trio
maurice richard jean béliveau et guy
lafleur sauf guy qui s'empressait de
faire remarquer les autres grands
joueurs qu'il avait côtoyés tout au long
de sa carrière
tant dans sa vie personnelle que
professionnelle
guy faisait les choses à sa façon
une amie de la famille merci carmen
comparez guy à un diamant brut c'est
vrai un diamant que personne mais
personne n'a réussi à polir et je lui
lève mon chapeau pour ça
je vais me souvenir longtemps comme vous
tous du grand hockeyeur qui l'a été avec
son coup de patin tellement naturel son
sourire sa chevelure au vent mais
surtout je vais me souvenir de l'homme
humble généreux droit intègre qu'il a
été
malgré son combat acharné contre le
cancer est en bout de ligne la maladie a
eu raison de lui je crois que guy n'a
pas dit son dernier mot
d'abord il laisse un peu de lui dans le
coeur non seulement des membres de sa
famille de sa belle famille et de ses
amis mais aussi
dans celui de chacun des québécois et
des québécoises de plus il s'est assuré
de par sa fondation de contribuer à
poursuivre la recherche médicale
au final je me plais à penser qu'il est
monté à bord de l'hélicoptère qui les
met en piloter et qu'il s'est envolé
fier de ce qu'il a accompli est libre
merci guy pour tous les beaux moments
que nous avons passés en famille et tout
le bon vin rouge que nous avons bu
ensemble surtout bon voyage
[Applaudissements]
place maintenant à madame ginette reno
comment
[ __ ]
[Musique]
l'essentiel c'est d'être aimé
le reste importe peu
la seule vérité
c'est compter pour quelqu'un
quoi qu'il puisse arriver
c'est entrer dans souquet
et non sortir jamais
c recevra rosa
qu'on aimerait étonné
ne plus s'appartenir
en être rassurés
de voir la joie de l'eau
sombre de bonhomme
mais les deux chats confiance
et devenir mai
les chansons
c'est être aimé
contrairement est
ce qu'on peut raconter
ce n'est pas la fortune
pour la célébrité
une ce que tu vaux
et ne font que passer
je crois
[Musique]
à
et depuis rien
est attendu le soir
et courir en chemin
un des plus beaux que dans
je nous y fait la vie
c'est quand notre prénom a l'air d'un
mot gentil qui
l'essentiel jour après jour
seul e ri aux éclats
dans leur van kim
et qu'une sont au coeur
en guise de conte
oh
je demande et du cul
look général jean tout
res importe quoi
la solidarité
j'ai compté pour quelqu'un
quoique et puisse arriver
être un jour etc si les
sommes payées tranché et avoir dans son
coeur
quelqu'un qui parle
c'est inspiré
ce dimanche simon
qui pour elle ou panchir
au delà
c'est d'être meilleur
bonjour
mon
[Musique]
en amont
[Applaudissements]
tournons nous vers le christ avec
confiance
en ne connaissant que nous sommes
pécheul et ouvrons nos coeurs à la
miséricorde de dieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que dieu tout puissant nous fasse
miséricorde que nous pardonne nos péchés
nous conduisent à la vie éternelle
prions le seigneur
seigneur dieu comprend fait la vie
présente
ouvre l'accès à la vie future
nous t'en prions fait que sous sa
conduite l'âme de ton serviteur guy
obtiennent de participer à la rédemption
éternel par jésus-christ ton fils notre
seigneur qui vit terrain avec trois
temps d'unités du saint-esprit dieu pour
les siècles des siècles
lecture du livre du prophète isaïe
en ce jour là le seigneur de l'univers
préparera pour tous les peuples un fait
c'est sur sa montagne
sur cette montagne il fera disparaître
le voile de deuil qui enveloppent tous
les peuples et le linceul qui couvre
toutes les nations il fera disparaître
la mort pour toujours
le seigneur dieu essuiera les l'arbre
sur tous les visages et par toute la
terre il effacera l'humiliation de son
peuple
le seigneur a parlé en ce jour là où on
dira voici notre dieu en lui nous
espérions et il nous a sauvés c'est lui
le seigneur en lui nous espérions
exultant
réjouissons nous il nous a sauvés parole
du seigneur
[Musique]
le
oh
et
auj
[Musique]
le
show
m
[Musique]
oh
et
voilà
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à reading lecture de la lettre de saint
paul aux romains
frères et soeurs tous ceux et celles qui
se laisse conduire par l'esprit de dieu
son fils et filles de dieu
vous n'avez pas reçu un esprit qui fait
de vous des esclaves et vous ramène à la
peur mais vous avez reçu un esprit qui
fait de foule et fils et des filles
c'est en lui que nous crions ah bah
c'est à dire père
oui c'est l'esprit c'est lui même qui
atteste à notre esprit que nous sommes
enfants de dieu puisque nous sommes ses
enfants nous sommes aussi ses héritiers
héritier de dieu héritier avec le christ
si du moins nous souffrons avec lui pour
être avec lui dans la gloire
parole du seigneur
[Musique]
oh
eh
oui
[Musique]
oh
l'évangile de jésus-christ selon
saint-jean
seigneur
en ce temps là
jésus disait ah si tu sais
que votre coeur ne soit pas bouleversée
croyez en dieu
croyez aussi à moi
dans la maison de mon père il ya de
nombreuses demain sinon pourrais je dise
je pars vous préparez une place quand je
serais parti vous préparez une place je
reviendrai et je vous ramènerai auprès
de moi afin que là où je suis vous soyez
vous aussi
pour aller où je vais vous savez le
chemin
thomas lui dit
seigneur nous savons pas où tu vois
comment pourrions-nous savoir le chemin
jésus répond moi je suis le chemin la
vérité et la vie personne ne voie vers
le père sans passer par moi
acclamant la parole de dieu nous
rejetons enseignants
aujourd'hui
nous nous retrouvons à l'assemblée par
guy lafleur
ses racines
étaient sa famille
sa passion
était largué
son modèle
était jean béliveau
son inspiration
était le public
son horizon
était de se dépasser sans cesse
ces plans seront des sagas
depuis le 22 avril nous sommes plongés
dans la tristesse et la gratitude
la tristesse d'avoir perdu un être cher
jacques gratitude pour sa vie de
générosité qui a rayonné dans toutes les
directions et qui a éclairé temps de vie
nous nous unissons à votre peine
et nous exprimons comment guy a été
important dans notre vie personnelle
familiale
et sociale
nous vous remercions pour votre propre
générosité
et par notre présence
en personne par les médias
nous vous assurons de notre compassion
pour vous en ce temps de deuil
et de notre soutien en pensée et en
prière
cad su que tu n'as pas reçus nous dit
saint paul
guy avait beaucoup au dessus
et sa joie était de donner le donner en
retour de partage et de la joie avec les
partisans et le grand public
son humilité en faisait un homme d'
équipe
toujours près des personnes
accessible et attentif
il signait volontiers des autographes et
donnait des poignées de mains sans
compter
et was great afrique c'était un grand
athlète
il rendait le jeu passionnant et jouer
chaque partie comme si tu as la dernière
en donnant le meilleur de lui-même en se
dépassant constamment
c'est aussi un homme courageux
et c'est devenu particulièrement évident
quand il est revenu au jeu après une
pause de quelques années
si sur la patinoire ils étaient les
compétiteurs déterminé en dehors de la
patinoire il était tout aussi déterminé
prêt à dire oui pour supporter toutes
les bonnes causes en particulier pour
les enfants défavorisés
il savait comment se dépasser pour
rencontrer les autres sur leur terrain
l'histoire de du gui
est l'histoire d'un coeur d'un coeur bat
à
dunkerque a tant battus d'un coeur qui
ne s'est jamais arrêté de battre
il a été disponible jusqu à dallas
maladie en se faisant solidaire des
malades
c'est une histoire de coeur entre guy sa
famille
le public
la population
qui se retrouvent en ces jours ci à un
passage
notre coeur endolori
par le décès d'un époux d'un père
de fils et d'un frère d'une amie et d'un
exemple
notre cas la soif
notre coeur la soif de mémoire
et les témoignages innombrables
d'affection se manifeste
notre coeur
a soif de présence
et nous quittons notre vie quotidienne
et nos engagements immédiats
pour nous laisser rassemblés par biais
pour accompagner sa famille faire corps
et prier pour lui
notre coeur a soif
d'un avenir plus grand
c'est un avenir plus grand que nous
ou le voile de deuil disparaît
ou la mort elle-même été transformé en
passage de ce monde à la vie éternelle
et où les retrouvailles remplacent les
solitudes et les larmes
voici notre dieu nous dit le
prophétisait y
il prépare pour nous le royaume de
l'amour infini et éternel
royaume de beauté de paix de vérité et
de bonté
il prépare pour nous ne demeure est une
fête ou là de tout ce que l'on peut
imaginer
une immense fête de famille où nous
sommes les enfants de dieu où nous
retrouverons nos proches et l'humanité
que votre coeur ne soit pas bouleversée
nous dit jésus
la vie et humaine est un don précieux
l effet pour recevoir la vie éternelle
comme don de dieu
notre soif est une soif d'absolu
et dieu l absolu qui vient à nous en
jésus-christ
l'homme l'abandon à dieu à travers la
mort est le dernier dépassement de soi
en ce monde
que l'on réalise en marchant sur les
traces de jésus est mort et ressuscité
le modèle par excellence qui frappent à
la porte dans notre coeur
chères familles de guy
nous nous unissons à votre prière
que je vous apporte des confort et
douceur
ils nous inspirent la solidarité
et qui l'accueille guy
dans sa miséricorde et sa joie
ensemble nous avons écouté la parole de
dieu qui nous invite à l'espérance que
notre prière au christ se fasse
maintenant humble et confiante
après chaque intention me répondront
souviens toi seigneur de ton amour
pour qui l'erreur
que nous confions maintenant à la
miséricorde de dieu
pour les défunts que nous avons connue
et aimée ensemble prions
pour nous tous ici rassemblés d'autres
fois soit plus forte que notre peine et
que nous n'allions pas sans espérance
ensemble prions
pour ceux et celles qui ont été éprouvés
par pandémie qui ne se croit pas
abandonnés de dieu et qu'il garde
confiance
ensemble prions
pour tous les enfants de dieu que leur
vie sur terre
deviennent plus fraternelle et plus
juste ensemble prions
pour notre mère l'église
qu'elle proclame fidèlement le mystère
du christ seigneur des vivants et des
morts
ensemble prions
seigneur jésus toi qui es là au milieu
des croyants l'assemblée en ton nom
écoutent leurs supplications et d'un gué
répondre à leurs appels fois qu'ils
visaient dingue pour les siècles des
siècles
[Musique]
c
et
oh
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et eux
là
[Musique]
oh
moi
[Musique]
oh
à
priez frères et soeurs que mon sacrifice
qui est aussi le vôtre soit agréable à
dieu de perdre tout puissant que le
seigneur reçoivent de vos mains ce
sacrifice à la louange à la gloire de
son nom pour notre bien et celui de
toute l'église
soit favorable en nous offrant de
seigneur que ton serviteur guy
parviennent à la gloire avec ton fils à
qui nous sommes unis par l'admirable
sacrement de son amour lui qui vit
terrain pour les siècles des siècles
le seigneur soit avec vous
élevons notre coeur
d'un don grâce au seigneur notre dieu
vaux
vraiment il est juste et bon pour ta loi
dès notre salut de t'offrir notre action
de grâce toujours et en tout lieu
seigneur perles très sain dieu éternel
et tout puissant par le christ notre
seigneur
c'est en lui car dès ce plan dit pour
nous
l'espérance de la résurrection
bienheureuse
ici la loi de la mort nous afflige la
promesse d'une mortalité nous apporte la
consolation
car pour ceux qui croient en toi
seigneur la vie est transformée elle
n'est pas enlever et lorsque préfet leur
séjour sur la terre ils ont déjà une
demeure éternelle dans les cieux c'est
pourquoi avec les anges et les archanges
avec les puissances d'en haut et tous
les esprits bien heureux nous sentons
l'hymne de ta droits des sans fin nous
proclamons
[Musique]
oh
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es vraiment sain dieu de l'univers il
est juste que toute la création proclame
ta louange car c'est toi qui donne la
vie c'est toi qui sanctifie toute chose
partons fait ce jésus christ notre
seigneur avec la puissance de l'esprit
saint et tu ne cesses de l'assemblée ton
peuple afin que du levant ou couchant du
soleil une offrande pur soit présenté à
ton nom c'est pourquoi nous te supplions
seigneur consacré toi même les offrandes
que nous apportons senti filets par ton
esprit pour qu'elle devienne le corps et
le sang de ton fils jésus christ notre
seigneur qui nous a dit de célébrer ce
mystère
danut même où il fut livrée il prit le
pain en te rendant grâce il dit la
bénédiction il rompit le pain le donne à
ses disciples en disant prenez et mangez
en tous ceci est mon corps livré pour
vous
[Musique]
de même après le repas ils trient la
coupe en te rendant grâce il dit la
bénédiction il donne à la coupe à ses
disciples en disant prenez buvez en tous
car ceci est la coupe de mon sens le
sens de l'alliance nouvelle et éternelle
qui sera versée pour vous et pour la
multitude ans d'émission dépêchez vous
fêter cela en mémoire de moi
les grains de mystères de la foi nous
annonçons amor seigneur jésus nous
proclamons tu as des élections nous
attendons la venue dans la loi
en faisant mémoire de ton fils de sa
passion qui nous sauve sa glorieuse des
élections de son ascension dans le ciel
alors que nous attendons sont des mires
événements nous t'offrons seigneur en
action de grâce ce sacrifice vivant et
sein de garde ou t'en prions l'oblation
le ton église et day le connais ton fils
qui selon sa volonté s'est offert en
sacrifice on ne les concilier avec toi
quand nous serons nous dit de son corps
et de son sang est rempli de l'esprit
saint accor de nous d'être seul corps
rien seul esprit dans le christ
que l'esprit-saint face de nous une
interne à la fronde à ta gloire pour que
nous obtenions un jour
l'héritage promis avec t il eu en
premier lieu la bienheureuse vierge
marie mère de dieu avec saint joseph son
époux les bienheureuses apôtres les
glorieux martyrs et tout laisser les
saintes qui ne cesse d'être cédée auprès
de toi et nous assure de ton secours
et maintenant que ceux qui ont seigneur
pour de sacrifice qui nous réconcilie
avec toi et ton au monde entier le salut
et la paix
approfondi la fois de ton église au long
de son chemin sur la terre véçu ton
serviteur ne pas de françois notre
chevet christian l'ensemble des évêques
les prêtres les diacres et tout le
peuple des racistes et
et coûteux
les prières de ta famille assemblée
devant toi
et ramène à toi très aisément tous tes
enfants dissipés si ce cadre trois
joueurs
souviens toi de guy qui a quitté ce
monde et que tu appelles auprès de toi
puisqu'il a été unie à la mort de ton
fils accord de lui de participer à sa
résurrection le jour où le christ
ressuscitera dans la chair ceux qui sont
morts et transformera nos pauvres car à
l'image son corps glorieux
souviens toi aussi de nos frères et
soeurs défunt
souviens-toi des personnes qui ont
quitté ce monde et trouve grâce devant
toi dans ta bienveillance le soin les
dans ton royaume où nous espérons être
comblée de talloires tous ensemble et
pour l'éternité
quand tu essuiera toute larme de nos
yeux en te voyant toi notre dieu tel que
tu es tout seront semblables
éternellement est ce enfin nous
centrerons ta louange par le christ
notre seigneur par qui tu donnes au
monde tout grâce et tout bien
par lui avec lui et en lui à toi dieu le
père tout puissant dans l'unité du
saint-esprit tout honneur et toute loi
pour les siècles des siècles amen
lyon celui qui ne cesse jamais de nous
regarder comme ses enfants bien aimé
notre père qui êtes aux cieux que ton
nom soit sanctifié que ton règne vienne
que ta volonté soit faite sur la terre
comme au ciel donne nous aujourd'hui
notre pain de ce jour par de nous nos
offenses comme nous pardonnons aussi à
ceux qui nous ont offensés et ne nous
laisse pas entrer en tentation mais
délivre nous du mal
des livres nous de tout mal seigneur et
donne la paix à notre temps soutenu par
un musée des cordes nous selon libéré de
tout péché à l'abri de toute épreuve
nous qui attendons que se réalise cette
vienne re espérances l'avènement de
jésus christ notre sauveur car c'est à
toi cap à sienne au zinc vicence et la
loi gressier et siècle seigneur
jésus-christ tu as dit à tes apôtres je
voulais cela paie je vous donne ma paie
ne regarde pas nos péchés mais la foi de
ton église ou que ta volonté sa complice
tonnes à lui toujours cette paix et
conduit l'avait l'unité parfaite
toi qui visait règne pour les siècles
des siècles
que la paix du seigneur soit toujours
avec vous
agneau de dieu qui enlève le péché du
monde sans pitié de nous agneau de dieu
quand lève les péchés du monde prend
pitié de nous agneau de dieu qui enlève
les péchés du monde donne-nous la paix
voici la noue de dieu voici celui qui
enlève les péchés du monde veut les
éviter ou le pas des noces de l'agneau
seigneur je ne suis pas in de te
recevoir mais elle est seulement une
parole et je serai guéri
m
[Musique]
et
non
e
[Musique]
et
oh
à
on a prévu comme vous voyez mesdames et
messieurs
3d
on leur offrir
alors non seulement ils sont des
spectateurs on a voulu à faire des
participants
à cette cérémonie
sa maman
c'est touchant pour ceux qui sont à
l'extérieur comme
quand on a vu sortir ces prêts est
atteint on ne vous oublie pas vous
suivez avec lyon cette cérémonie
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
quoi
c
[Musique]
mais
prions le seigneur
accor de seniors à ton serviteur guy
demeure de lumière et de paix car c'est
pour lui que nous avons célébré le
sacrement pascal par le christ notre
seigneur
venez vous asseoir
notre frère guy s'est endormi dans la
paix du christ
confions de à l'amour de dieu notre père
dans la foi en la vie éternelle
avec respect et affection
accompagnons le de notre prière dans
l'espérance de nous retrouver un jour
quand dieu nous réunir à ajoie de son
royaume
de crayon nous
en passant tout ce que nous avons vécu
avec guy à ce qu'il est pour nous à ce
qu'il est pour dieu
que l'encens monte devant dieu avec
notre player
en signe de son baptême et de notre foi
en la résurrection que son corps soit à
beni
[Musique]
ça
je
oui
[Musique]
selva
non
oui
[Musique]
on
il
[Musique]
l'anonymat
et
[Musique]
oh
non
les mots
oh
[Musique]
mais où
non
[Musique]
m
c
[Musique]
ouais
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
et
bon
[Musique]
m
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
seigneur notre dieu
nous te recommandons notre frère guy
ton amour la compagnie tout au long de
sa vie
il a quitté ce monde qui passe
conduirait auprès de toi ou n'y a plus
ni deuil ni l'art ni douleur mais la
joie et la paix avec ton fils et
l'esprit saint pour les siècles des
siècles
le seigneur soit avec vous
que dieu tout puissant vous bénisse le
père le fils et le saint-esprit
aller dans la paix du christ
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
sora fait
enfin en queue
[Musique]
bref un
on sait depuis
pas moi
[Musique]
ah ouais la typo
travaux
[Musique]
de ferreira loué
à mo
[Musique]
matthew gordon
d
[Musique]
oui
à fumer
c'est la bière
[Musique]
je mène chez nous
a été
[Musique]
100 m
l'exigence de 30
et ce capot
[Musique]
moins de six mois
/
[Musique]
pas chez nous une
na
ça
paroisse de bons
sow
[Musique]
c'est
la charge
non
[Musique]
à 2
o o
[Musique]
l'école
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yes
et brosse morts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des milliers de personnes sur le parvis
qui ont le frisson mesdames et messieurs
de plus en plus de gens d'ailleurs qui
sont arrivés au cours de cette cérémonie
pendant qu'on voit la famille de
monsieur lafleur qui partent vers leur
cérémonie privée une cérémonie que guy
lafleur aurait aimé simple direct
beaucoup d'émotion
plus de flafla pas de temps perdu comme
il les met des emportements oui
pendant qu'on écoute les gens qui lui
disent un dernier au revoir
à ces lots
les cf-18 sont venus dire au revoir à
qui la fleur les escadrons
lui qui amène un l'aviation des
hélicoptères des forces canadiennes ils
ont rendu avec ce clin d'oeil les avions
qui viennent de passer à basse altitude
devant la cathédrale
marie-reine-du-monde une cérémonie avec
des temps forts vous l'avez vécu avec
nous ou contre nous le discours de
patrick roy entre autres des des appels
à la bonté et la reconnaissance que cet
homme là était bon il faisait du bien il
faisait une différence autour de lui
patrick roy qui a dit des gens rêvaient
d'être qui la fleur moi je rêvais d'être
ken dryden pour jouer dans l'équipe de
guy lafleur
vraiment une heure jean-françois une
cérémonie
à l'image de celle emploi qu'un on a eu
cette image des prêtres qui sont sortis
voir la foule pour offrir la communion
ça disait beaucoup de choses et on
oublie pas lui n'a pas oublié d'où il
venait de thurso et c'est comme si on
n'avait pas au blick avait des gens à
l'extérieur ordinaire des fans venus le
voir
cérémonie qu il avait peut-être environ
1000 personnes mais là il y en a
beaucoup plus quelques milliers
maintenant qu'ils sont tout près de la
cathédrale marie-reine-du-monde et
je prends des paroles de
capitaine il va en cornouailles et si tu
veux faire un autre que tour guy et on
est ouverts parce que monsieur cournoyer
qui avait fait un disque au
japon
alors que corchia qui au
dernier adieu
en images ou plus et lapointe cambre
sanou et kiki
[Applaudissements]
on est arrivé avec cette image de la
densité des gens se sont massés le long
de la clôture ce rené lévesque but
d'emerse un peu trompeur mêlant joie il
ya eu beaucoup de gens queen mansfield
rené lévesque s'est plaint devant droit
déjà qu'ils sont venus pour l'heure du
dîner qui travaillent centre ville sont
venus pour ça bien sûr énormément de
chandelles qui qu'à regarder ses
coéquipiers juste de vin et tous les
invités qui sont là applaudir sur le
paradis
c'est bon monsieur legault qui quitte
avec son épouse la mairesse de montréal
qui est là les dignitaires qui quêtent
sur les
ceux qui sont sur le parvis monsieur
trudeau sophie grégoire trudeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors mission réussie pour les
organisateurs de cette cérémonie le qui
était comme je le disais lui n'avait pas
les dés ne veux pas parler pour rien ne
met pas les longs discours c'est une
cérémonie qui est allé sans jeu de mots
à l'essentiel avec cette magnifique
chanson aussi de ginette reno qui n'ont
rien laissé paraître de ces deux
problèmes de santé récent elle a été
radiée resplendissante devant des
invités la famille et je retiens aussi
le discours de son fils martin lafleur
qui
ne pas cacher comme on dit
est demeuré très émotif évidemment et a
tenu à remercier
les québécois les fan's de guy lafleur
son père qui est qui qui ont été
merveilleux si je reprends son
expression je reprends une ligne de la
chanson l'essentiel est amusant parce
que ginette qui a avec sa facilité
les paroles cessé quand notre prénom a
l'air d'un mot gentil et elle a dit guy
guy les gens eu des frissons dans
l'église
vraiment c'était des touches
intelligente avec beaucoup d'émotion bon
merci à mozart merci à forer merci à bas
coûts aussi parce que la musique a aidé
à magnifier
magnifier ce moment
ici en direct à montréal alors que vous
continuez à voir les joueurs les amis
les militaires qui quitte
et aussi la la soeur de l'épousé donc de
guy lafleur hocine ben ali qui a pris la
parole ou c'est la toute fin et qui a
rappelé à quel point guy lafleur
on dérangeait jamais chaque fois qu'il
était quelque part en train de prendre
un repas avec les siens il ya toujours
quelqu'un dit c'est elle qui venait à sa
rencontre et jamais guy lafleur elle l'a
répété ne refusait et ne faisait pas que
signer d'autographes mais aussi poser
des questions et ça ça veut bien si
souvent que vous avez vu défiler
aujourd'hui dans des missions d des
photos de france de guy lafleur on leur
avait demandé de les envoyer et ça aussi
ça s'est tellement signifiant descriptif
de qui et guy lafleur
les les gens qui est qui marche qui
suivent le cortège qui va aller dans un
lieu privé bien sûr c'est la partie
privée après des funérailles qui se
poursuit
on a vu cette image de l'istia laflaque
a
salué les gens sur le parvis qui était
ému
elle était très très émue elle a levé la
main pour
saluer les gens qui ont regardé cette
cérémonie sur écrans géants pendant
qu'on voit
la cathédrale se vider monsieur savard
qui est en discussion
avec jeff monson je crois je le vois
deux aubrac se consomme cathédrale
marie-reine-du-monde qui je le rappelle
est la réplique de saint pierre de rome
mauro quatre choix plus petit mais
n'empêche c'est la réplique exacte de
saint pierre de rome la seule à
l'extérieur la seule réplique sur la
planète et c'est là qu'on a vécu en 2014
les funérailles de jean béliveau s'est y
avait une tempête de neige cet
abominable comme un été haut aujourd'hui
ce un clin d'oeil à la météo aujourd'hui
le soleil est sorti panne a lacéré bruit
un peu avant elle elle est parti se
coucher mais on avait permis ou 5
centaine de personnes du public
d'assister à la cérémonie aux obsèques
dans cette magnifique enceinte
franchement est ce ta triste lorsque le
cercueil de guy lafleur a quitté la
cathédrale il ya eu un moment de frisson
général ces témoignages franchement
fallait se ressaisir parce que nous
sommes tous voulaient est un fan de gi
la fois comme tout nous avons rêvé
d'être qu'il a peur on l'a entendu si
souvent et lorsque vous voyez votre
idole affaires sont son change
nos adieux dans la faune à guy lafleur
et ça se passe devant vos yeux ben c'est
poignant c'est je pense que tous ceux
qui nous écoutent avait probablement
mais même sans cela
très bien on ira sur le parvis on ira
parler à des gens marc isabelle est
hélas déjà j'aimerais entendre les gens
qu'est ce qu'ils ont passés de cette
cérémonie
mais écoutez je pense que les gens
étaient très émus très touchée justement
par les différents témoignages la
musique aussi et je me trouve justement
avec une dame qui a pas que écouter la
cérémonie depuis le début en fait
quelques l événement quel moment vous a
le plus marqué cette cérémonie là
ben en général j'ai tout aimé la du
début à la fin ben qu'est-ce que j'ai
assisté jusqu'à la fin surtout les le
coeur le cas puis giner dia qu'elles
sont chantés l'essentiel c'était
vraiment c'est merveilleux c'était beau
c'est vraiment touchant de voir ça de
voir toutes ces personnes ici dans la
foule aussi avait quand même beaucoup de
gens oui en d'andorre partout c'était
vraiment
ça comme un moment solennel
oui je vous remercie beaucoup merci donc
on voit déjà quand même plusieurs
personnes qui commencent à quitter mais
vraiment beaucoup de gens qui étaient
rassemblés comme vous le voyez là
très bien denis coderre est avec diane
sauvé on les écoute
monsieur coderre quelles sont vos
premières impressions à la suite de
cette série est extraordinaire c'était
c'était dur espèce de la sobriété
mystère profond on sentait l'angle mêmes
guillot ranger les de la température
pour pour l'apport pour la population
c'était bien c'était bien senti j'ai
adoré les témoignages la soeur de l'iss
qui était aussi exceptionnelle on
sentait vraiment alors que c'était
l'amour à l'état pur c'était à son image
aussi oui c'était c'était france était
direct percutant mais c'était un jean
être nous donc on va pleurer je n'ai pas
encore la dernière fois que j'ai une
anecdote parce que quand j'étais maire
de montréal on avait fait était là
armstead et puis j'avais un tour
d'hélicoptère oms en avant en
hélicoptère avec guy lafleur et ginette
reno compte de sa grossesse n'a pas à
cause des turbulences
c'est un magnifique depuis on voit que
c'est dû à une complicité exceptionnelle
hors cadre de chantiers de l'essentiel
de on peut pas faire autrement que
verser quelques larmes beaucoup
voient la phrase c'est un bon résumé
c'est une cérémonie encore une fois on a
on a n'a pas mis plus qu'il fallait on a
été plus direct on était d'ailleurs plus
rapide il aurait apprécié monsieur
lafleur on a été plus rapide que le plat
j'en ai fait quelques jeunes mesdames et
messieurs de ses funérailles nationales
aux funérailles tout court et c'est
plutôt rare qu'on arrive plutôt à la
ligne d'arrivée et c'est ce qui est
arrivé aujourd'hui on a décidé d'enlever
quelques partis pour garder
l'essentiel je répète ce jeu de mot avec
ginette reno madame reno qui a eu la
générosité d'accepter l'invitation des
organisateurs du canadien du
gouvernement
également les discours revenons sur les
à monsieur carbonite avec diana aurait
on va écouter monsieur carbonneau
convient
guy tu as été très éloquent lors de ton
de son allocution qu est ce que tu
voulais absolument faire ressortir
les gens ont la chance de voir guy
lafleur ou de le voir à la télévision
performer
mais en arrière de cet homme là qui
était une grande grande vedette avec
quelqu'un qui était très très simple et
moi c'est de cette façon alors gelé
connu c'est que c'est je pense que c'est
important la majorité des personnes qui
ont été capables de parler à son honneur
à ces
cérémonies là quand surseoir de ce que
sentimentaux nîmes
ces deux mois comment c'était non
seulement un très bon joueur qui m est
un grand homme piqué qui a frappé non
seulement les fans par kim et la
population du québec du canada puis
partout dans le monde c'était un grand
un grand capital qu'est ce qui te
remarquée de chedly ben c'est sa
simplicité c'est comme ensuite
accessible à tout le monde malgré le
fait qu'ils étaient garés pu être
facilement
ac est isolé puis de parler aux jeunes
mais c'était quelqu'un qui dit geagea
maison
bonjour monsieur perron
je vais enchaîner avec jean perrin jean
perron quel sentiment vous anime la
sortie de cette cérémonie de guy lafleur
ça la hauteur de nos attentes l'autre
comme baptisèrent joueurs
comme un dirigeant c'est
un monument guy lafleur appui après ce
qu'on a entendu des joies baptiste est
toujours
un gosse 5 généreux
on a récusé vous c'est qui qui
fonctionnait à 100 milles à l'heure
c'est trop facile de suivre il moi
j'allais de l'est connu dans diverses
constante ce pays
le projet longtemps je sois au moins
propres et sobres a pris sa retraite
mais ça a été un homme
extraordinaire tri nations passons sylla
lui l'autre bout avoir fait des
remarques d'années qui vise l
organisation mais c'étaient les romains
du peuple mais le peuple est attendu à
cesser ces choses là puis c'est la
raison pour laquelle on l'est mais était
là au niveau de tout le monde de tous
les vaccins pouvaient s'adresser à un
ministre comme ça s'adressait aux gens
de la rue puis cet appareil pour lui tu
qu'avec un sens du mot comme des gens
disaient c'est vraiment à quel point
vous avez eu vous avez senti l'effet
qu'il ya eu sur les joueurs
baisse
au niveau au niveau des joueurs c'était
assez tel le capitaine laure c'était
c'était lui qui dirigea t'attends tu
leur as lui quand moi je n'ai pas connu
une assez meilleures années comme joueur
parce que c'était au nouveau brunswick a
entamé à jean que le père yama comptait
et 10e gala ici ils pouvaient lever
jusqu'à 3 4 heures du matin via rivés
sur la patinoire après y'a pas aussi des
sea dogs darondel je n'ai pas personne
d'autre qui lui a enlevé l'or il était
tellement supérieur à tout le monde mais
que vous faites avec simplicité et
humour il s'est jamais pris pour un
autre puits pour ça que tout le monde
l'aiment merci beaucoup mais c'est un
creuset
voilà si jamais pris pour un autre mais
y était dans une classe à part ça c'est
clair il va convoyer et sur le pari
qu'un joueur doit être
avec lui ça nous a permis de remercier
sans polak parce qu'il nous a permis
d'avoir guy pour de longues années et
d'avoir gagné cinq coupes stanley avec
moi vous sentez aujourd'hui après la
cérémonie comme seule
saison
merci
faut pas oublier ça cet aspect là de ses
ses camarades de l'époque tu extrêmement
dur les perdent quelqu'un d'important
pour eux c'est leur souvenir s'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui s'envole avec le
cercueil qu'est partie la tour de rôle
je suis bien discours de dix ans comme
loyer à jean béliveau mon capitaine nous
avait émus encore une fois aujourd'hui
et yvan cournoyer qui doit prendre la
parole vous le voyez très ému d'ailleurs
savez que il va encore noyé lors des
premières années de guy lafleur les
premières années de la flore ne réussit
pas à s'imposer
et avec ce quartier beaumont et c'est
comme loyer qui veut dire à la flore
sois toi même session avec lui et ça
déclenche est exactement arrête de
penser être un autre sois toi même
monsieur savard qui est avec diane
se savoir
quelles sont vos impressions de cette
cérémonie bas j'étais très belle
cérémonie est bien là bas j'avais le
mari guy je pense que c'est j'étais sa
hauteur puis avec tout ce qu'il a fait
puis il l'a marqué l'essai par partout
sauf dans populations disent qu'avec
partout au canada mme surtout ici
le monde qui comme jean béliveau
familiaux 8mm placide puis c'est quand
même le peuple s'est retrouvé derrière
ce gars là la seule grande de sauver de
quitter très humble puis contrairement à
beaucoup de grands joueurs aussi qui ont
vu pour d'autres équipes qui ont jamais
gagné ici souvent alain année sur deux
sera alimenté quelques parades sur la
rue 180 que salam et youri chose ça
aussi mais moi comme j'ai été si mal
privilégié d'avoir joué dix ans avec lui
puis c'était pendant au moins 6 à l'oeil
a complètement dominé la ligue nationale
et c'était un plaisir pour tous ses
coéquipiers de tout rendu meilleur plus
on avait une équipe est assez
extraordinaire mais c'est assez
incroyable de savoir qu'ils aient pensé
à son monde jusqu'à la fin parce que
quatre aides qui sont sortis ici pour
donner l'eucharistie aux gens dehors
c'est vraiment à son image by garde de
juger juste les dernières les derniers
mois de sa vie il y avait un fond pour
pour le chemin vraiment c'est près de 2
millions et chaque fois à chaque
personne qui ont donné qu'ils donnaient
montage voir culture quel montant il
appelé personnellement c'est amené
jusque les dernières semaines de sa vie
les concerts
bon j'ai beaucoup de temps à appeler le
monde puis d'anata de chemin
avec nous ce qui fait une différence pis
ça fameux dieu et dis moi et je suis je
pour moi qui va profiter médiane qui va
projeter dans le futur 5e un outrage
qu'à la fin puis a été bon toute bonne
personne si beaucoup mais c'est simple
oui c'était c'était une bonne personne
pendant qu'on voit les gens quittent est
derrière nous beaucoup de gens qui
discutent qui tiennent à ce que ce temps
salon où je s'allonge un peu baril il
avait vous êtes avec encore des gens du
public
oui tout à fait et je me trouve avec
richard blais qui y venu avec son
drapeau on l'a vu très ému tout au long
de la cérémonie monsieur blais je
voulais vous demander qu'est ce qui vous
a le plus marqué de cette cérémonie là
on a sermonné moi j'ai trouvé que
excusé j'ai trouvé que la cérémonie et a
très très bien fait merci monsieur mason
ça a été fait avec beaucoup beaucoup de
respect et c'est que c'est qu'on voulait
parce que guy lafleur c'est un gars très
respectueux et le nord assez partagé je
suis très très très honoré de ça ça
s'est très très bien fait
on vous a vu très touchée faisant
presque
pleuré oui
disons que c'est c'est sa date de loin
ça a commencé avec mon grand-père son
idole et à maurice richard après ça il
ya envoyé le flambeau à mon père qui
était jean béliveau et mon père me l'a
transféré avec guy lafleur mais on peut
dire que le flambeau s'est éteint il
reste plus il reste plus vraiment
personne
aussi grand que c'est trop tôt
mais je l'espère avec ce qui s'en vient
ça regarde très très bien
puis j'espère qu'on va vivre notre coq
d'oubli très bientôt je l'attends avec
impatience avant de mourir
sur le chablais merci beaucoup ça va
merci
vous avez remarqué mesdames et messieurs
qu'on a remis les photos au nom de vos
photos que vous nous avez envoyé on en a
comme ça on pourrait faire tout l'après
midi des alors merci encore d'avoir eu
cette attention et on est avec francis
bouillon sur le parvis
c'était tellement important de
données de redonner pour lui faisais
tellement sentir les gens bien ses
impressionnantes les gens devant guy
lafleur était froid puis après après 30
secondes c'était quasiment comme gérer
c'est comme si le monde venait sont à me
battre pour moi c'est comme tellement
impressionnant de voir ça puis comme je
dis moi j'ai fait ma carrière j'ai cédé
comme ça tout au long de ma carrière je
trouvais un trek les anciens jeudi ben
c'est tellement ce que je voulais que je
voulais être guy lafleur je pense à
l'intérieur de nous on voulait tout être
un guy lafleur un régent aux leurs ils
vont l'avoir en les voyant agir
exactement parce que tu leur as côtoyé
pendant plusieurs années sur sort à
peine de cette cérémonie la caisse que
c'est quoi tes impressions basse ça a
été comme je vous disais 1
un mélange d'émotions as a été très
triste d'être une autre et la grande
ginette que le prix le champ je pense
qu'on les papillons à l'intérieur mais
après ce que tu dis mais à l'image de
guy lafleur aurait voulu que tout le
monde se réunissent tout le monde puis
c'est juste qu'on remercie et quasi de
montréal on remercie beaucoup la famille
de le partager parce que je suis sûr que
guy lafleur avait voulu que le public le
voit et le public participation aussi
puis c'est tout à l'honneur du canadien
de sa famille de savoir que tu as porté
le même le goc lui c'est grandiose si je
me suis au début maurice richard était
leur fille pour moi c'est un work est ce
qui se passe ici là c'est j'arrive à
quel sens en étant année table ce qui
des deux grandi à montréal en laize à
montréal où on avait des rails mais que
les règles de vie réalité de la chance
de côtoyer ces gens là puis de
partage un peu leur histoire mais monde
est aujourd'hui avec le développement
toujours à l'emploi du canadien c'est ce
que j'essaie de faire avec les jeunes
espoirs du canadien aussi de partager
d'être un menteur ces jeunes élèves de
partager l'histoire canadienne montreal
quel héritage il va avoir les c ah ben
c'est énorme je pense que c'est un
héritage au québec au complet de bonté
même site est grandiose était dans le
thé dans les tops personnalité mais de
rester n 2 reste unique de
2000 monde géant au grand carbet
actuellement exactement merci beaucoup
français merci c'est gentil hacker
parfaite
sympathique francis bouillon ancien
joueur du canadien on va aller dire un
mot en région avant de quitter les gens
vous avez eu l'occasion de suivre ça de
taf le ride c'est je le disais ce n'est
pas son image il y avait peu il ya plus
de flafla cérémonie beaucoup d'émotion
si rapide on va à l'essentiel
qu'est ce que tu as pensé
qu'est ce que j'ai pensé c'est ça j'ai
trouvé que ça répondait à ce qu'on a
senti dès le début c'est c'est guy
lafleur c'est une gymnastique mais c'est
comme c'est comme une fierté nationale
qui c'est comme si je faisais un
transfert je sais pas si ça te frapper
mais
employés mais surtout carbo et matri
croissant de cette génération là dans le
chemin de 2,2 du québec inc on parle
strictement français c'est le canadien
l'annonceur maison qui a fait le numéro
19 nombreux d'haïti comme si on était
une mauvaise game au forum mais pour
tout le reste c'était fait avec 7 à la
fois de proches des gens proches de ces
des funérailles nationales proche de la
nation jusqu'à la dernière seconde les
élèves
les jets militaires sont partis de
bagotville pour avancer au sucre pour
rappeler que guy lafleur était un membre
en orage par colonel honoraire
oui et et ginette reno et mazan c'est
grandiose les requiem mêmes il y en a
composé juste le premier mouvman
médicaux c'est le cas ça reste mon nom
mais mais c'est ginette reno est
indirecte en direct dans des cas et
c'était la première fois que j'écoutais
la chanson les mots vrais mâles est ce
que ça faisait
j'ai quelqu'un boutade moi il y avait
les larmes aux yeux durs sont
ces produits que mon coeur
que vous disiez j'ai eu la même remarque
c'est la première fois que je suis même
allé voir les paroles après qu'on
écoutait cette chanson là qu'elle a pris
une autre dimension
c'est sûr j'ai pas eu le temps d'avoir
votre réponse tout à l'heure je vous ai
demandé est ce que lui bon il y avait
fait la paix s vous m'avez répondu mais
ce que lui savait qu'il représentait à
ce point la fierté de tout un peuple
il le vaste champ de la position de mes
dépôts consciente de ça je vais parler a
si souvent intraday de tout le monde si
mode séparatistes loupé mais dit la nisa
selon lui
la france savait qu'il y avait un amour
baer dans les deux sens et c'est pour ça
que si c'était un as mangé avec lui
benton le soir où josé théodore a mis
cette chute lors ils faisaient le match
en plein air et j'avais mangé avec lui
utilise la veille au château lacombe a
au sérieux comment ce qui faisait voici
peu plus agressif dans sa vie il y avait
vraiment allemand
[Rires]
et tout le monde tout le monde mais là
on était à edmonton on n'était pas
bercer vise
comme ça tout le temple ram auto et moto
c'était obligé d'être sécurité parce que
le monde râle à simple pour aller assez
de suite plus longtemps puis c'était un
monde où l'on voit ça d'un millier
patrice
maintenant du vélo qui sont connus des
frissons quand le cercueil est sorti
d'ici vraiment le jeu on est emporté
jeudi aux collègues qui ont jamais fait
funeral on est porté par une vague b de
la vague est assez autres merci même si
important non mais y avait beaucoup de
monde c est dense mais il y avait
quelque chose de
profond qui s'est passé en tout cas
salut réjean tremblay merci de votre
fleuriste de nous avons parlé mais des
mails on reprend le travail demain
salut paris enrico ciccone
ces commentaires après la cérémonie il
est avec diane
enrico je me permets de te tutoyer tes
impressions sur 102 ça dans quel état
mais très émotif ça a été ça n'a pas été
facile mais c'était vraiment la grandeur
à la hauteur de nos hommes là c'était un
bon d'entendre tout ce qu'il ya tout ce
qui a été dit
c'était un mot sur la touche énormément
c'est d'avoir nos idoles seller guy
lapointe les niveaux la balle et mario
tremblay qui ont poussé cercueil puis
tiff comprendre on ne vit qu'avec les
autres on les a aimés sont plus guère
plus gros que nature ces gars là sont et
font des ongles athènes puis ça a été
notre force quand on était jeunes depuis
des mois de voir ces gars là avoir
énormément thème pour personne ça m'a
vraiment des mois de voir si tu l'a
côtoyé toi guy mais c'est sûr que guy
j'ai commencé à côtoyer cagire que mon
entraîneur national quand on a commencé
à faire des événements qui a hérité de
ses fils étaient des tournois de golf et
l'a immédiatement
il m'a fait ça c'est comme si je faisais
partie de la gagne je joue à manger
rallye national party la gagne de guy
lafleur lui même se faisant pas partie
de journée 700 parties saillantes cas
mais c'est la confrérie du par la suite
mais quand j'ai joué pour le canadien
mais là encore plus grande partie de la
famille puisse et c'est des moments
exceptionnels que tu vis avec ton idole
parce que mouchard su privilégier dit
que mon idole mais ça a été mon job mon
home doors qui on a fait une tournée
pendant 15 ans avec les anciens
canadiens puis ça ça va toujours gardé
sa mémoire le restant de mes jours fous
de quelle façon ils te ra marquettois
ben écoute moi justice - les choses que
j'ai un pays vraiment de lui c'est de
prendre de temps déjà que j'avais des
belles valeurs et mes parents me
disaient toujours au garage en mégots
signer votre la façon vous signez vous
vos autres gaffes assurez-vous que ce
soit lisible prenez le tapis t on
prenait le thème et des fois ils nous le
disent elle dégage tu avais de sortie de
la chambre si vous voulez sortir c'est à
sortir parce que j parce que guy attirer
les faunes comme ça ce pont puis des
fonds n'était dans l'autobus qui on
l'attendait une arme parce que lui
signait tout le monde c'était ça c'est
une sortie l'idée par exemple puis on
regardait alips était
c'était comme si on était capable
d'apprendre que de voir quel genre de
gros qui l'étaient parce que moi dans ma
ville j'ai vu deux personnes avec une
prestance ou quelqu'un qui vont rentrer
dans une salle puis pendant une seconde
ça va donner silencieux j'ai vu monsieur
béliveau faire ce j'ai vu guy lafleur
fait cai de la fratrie d'un salon des
anciens pendant une fraction de seconde
ces dernières silencieux dire au besoin
de parler l'homme est arrivé et les
conversations continuer mais ça c'est la
présence que guy lafleur avait poussé
peau douce au québec c'est un vraiment
traversé la frontière c'était au canada
parce qu'on faisait une tournée au
canada que des anciens puis même aux
états unis de on était aux états unis
puis de la force était certaine légende
mais oui c'était flower josé s'était
c'était une des jambes puis je vous dire
une chose nous le convoyer les jeunes
l'appli flower lui et merci menzo tom
joad or qui on disait y ait un peu de
respect c'est monsieur lafleur mais lui
il voulait que les gens l'appellent
flower on voulait cette proximité là
c'est un peu l'idole de tout un peuple
et de quelle façon qu'est ce qui va nous
laisser à nous petits petits des membres
du peuple on n'a pas joué au hockey avec
oui mais c'est que l'authenticité moi je
pense que c'est le mot qu'il faut
revenir avec guy lafleur puis même moi
aujourd'hui à la politique là j'attends
d'être le plus attentifs possible quand
j'ai croisé falls et même ça plait pas
je le dis
c'est parce que quand tu parles avec ton
coeur mais habituellement ne t'a pas mal
toujours raison mais guy lafleur c'est
soyez authentiks p2 le message qu'on
pourrait laisser tout le monde s'y met
le son merci beaucoup merci ziane merci
elle rit coach icaunais on se rassure
show claudine bonjour vous êtes devant
la statue et où il ya l'empreinte de sa
main derrière ça c'est impressionnant il
avait il y avait mis sa main sur sa
cuisse puis on peut mesurer à quel point
il y avait des mains fortes et
grandement bref comment ça comme on a
vécu stature chauffe
ça c'est vraiment pas assez je voudrais
dans la sphère privée parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de cérémonie officielle
ici ni d'écran ayant pour justement
diffuser les funérailles nationales
donc ça s'est passé un peu de façon
solennelle on a vu beaucoup même des
dernières minutes des gens venir déposer
des nouvelles gerbe de fleurs sur devant
sombre on se prend en photo aussi devant
son bronze et n'allez pas croire qu'on
n'était pas en deuil ici la seule chose
c'est que c'était vraiment dans la
sphère privée alors les gens devant leur
téléviseur ont écouté avec intérêt ou
enregistrer cette cérémonie ses
funérailles nationales non c'est
d'ailleurs rendu vous allez vont des
images d'une résidence pour personnes
âgées ont fait rendu à cet endroit
pourquoi parce que ce sont justement ces
personnes qui ont côtoyé guy lorsqu'il
vivait justement à thurso petit garçon
qui l'ont vu évoluer une dame entre
autres que son fils jouer au hockey avec
qui elle avait l'anecdote suivante
concernant la coupe stanley à nous
donner
ça nous a toujours notre sigaud parce
que quand il y aura la coupe la haye est
venu apporter chez nous
quelques heures et on invite bien
moderne pour fêter le groupe et puis
tant que parti du lot choix de ne pas
faire rentrer dans le derrière dans mon
champ tout cela la coupe et d'arvalis
pour vous puis je voudrais jouer avec
maryvonne accident bon d'idiot les bains
on
les mains guidon l'entendue beaucoup ici
puis j'ai envie de vous dire une autre
question qu'on m'a beaucoup posé sa
savoir à quel endroit est ce qu on avait
l'intention bon dentellerie guias que
l'endroit est ce qu'il était pour se
retrouver on sait que la famille devrait
faire part de sa décision bon un peu
plus tard donc on n'a pas de réponse
encore à ce point ci à cette question
mais une chose qui est revenu souvent et
qui est revenu souvent faut le dire le
durant l'émission spéciale sait à quel
point il était généreux de son temps ici
les gens ont des photos des anecdotes
des signatures à nous montrer de sa part
d'ailleurs j'ai rencontré un homme qui
lui avait un album complet à l'éffigie
de guy lafleur
nous monsieur lafleur ici
on le connaît bien et puis on y dit
disent inquiets qu'ils voient sous verre
ils ont honnêtement ça nous touche
beaucoup plus on n'a pas besoin craintes
aussi généreux généreux pour toutes les
relations publiques il y avait pas deux
mesures' était vraiment
vraiment vraiment bon pour tous les gens
qui
qui pouvait leur rencontre il donna des
autographes 10 x y et à 12 heures de
temps qu'ils étaient dopés jusqu'au
dernier
voilà jusqu'au dernier ça c'est beaucoup
revenus c'était une règle de respect
chez monsieur lafleur de signer son
autographe jusqu'à la dernière personne
comme là il serait encore si c'était les
funérailles d'un autre il sera encore là
en train de signer chez les derniers qui
restent ici merci beaucoup claudine à
thurso s'est apprécié et jouf entend
mesdames et messieurs des gens qui
étaient justement derrière leurs
impressions de cette cérémonie
puis c'est triste mais que voulez vous
c'est la vie
les lèvres patrick roy
qu'est ce qu'ils disent qui es-tu tout
qu'est ce qui nous met reda sans partage
ça m'a beaucoup ému puis la chanson de
ginette reno see donc
l'essentiel c'est de sa vie qui la fleur
est partie malheureusement cause des
maladies faut juste la leçon qu'il faut
jamais prendre à rien pour acquis dans
vie puis c'est d'être fort
la personne qui t'a pas là aujourd'hui
remarqué quelque chose
donc moi je tenais personnellement ici
parce que guy lafleur fait partie de mon
enfance j'ai 44 ans puis j'ai grandi
avec ben moi puis ma mère on est à deux
maniaques du canadien j'ai grandi avec
sopi ma mère est malheureusement décédée
à 95 mais j'ai continué à garder cet
amour lowepro ch je pense que je les
tatouer sur le cap et mumbai et bleu
blanc rouge puis avon il va toujours
être comme ça jusqu'à fin 2000 où tu
m'aimes là mais quelques joints entre